contre c'est sur Public Sénat à 18h30 et
22h30 bonjour à tous ravi de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne un débat dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat sur la situation
des département d'outrem ce sont les
sénateurs de la mission d'information
commune du Sénat sur l'outrem qui ont
demandé l'INCR ins iption de ce débat à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat je vous
rappelle que cette mission avait été
constituée suite au mouvement de grève
générale aux Antilles en janvier 2009
depuis les sénateurs ont rendu leur
rapport dans lequel ils formulent 100
propositions pour l'avenir de
l'outromire au niveau national la
restitution des états généraux de
l'outrem s'est tenue il y a 3 semaines
des propositions concrètes ont été
formulées sur le pouvoir d'achat la
formation des prix la concurrence mais
également les problèmes de société et de
culture sans oublier le lien entre
l'État et l'outreemire c'est donc sur
ces propositions que les sénateurs
entendent revenir aujourd'hui avec ce
débat ils interrogent marielus Panchard
la secrétaire d'État à l'outreemire
bonne matinée à tous sur Public Sénat
chers collègues nous allons maintenant
procéder au débat interactif et spontané
dont la durée maximale a été fixée à
2h chaque sénateur peut intervenir pour
2 minutes maximum la mission est où le
gouvernement
la mission et le
gouvernement peuvent répondre je crois
que déjà monsieur
Longuet a demandé la parole vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président pour 2
minutes monsieur frima oui merci
monsieur le Président je ne les
utiliserai pas premièrement je voudrais
présenter à mes collègues des excuses
pour ne pas avoir participé à la
totalité du débat qui était riche et
passionnant mais j'étais retenu par le
déplacement du président de la
République s'exprimant sur les
collectivités locales à
saint-disier je ne suis pas non plus le
plus compétent du groupe UMP en matière
de département et territoire d'outrem de
cette France ultramarine mais le groupe
a estimé qu'il n'estit pas inutile que
le président questionne le ministre ou
le rapporteur et sur un sujet qui sera
extrêmement technique pardonnez-moi je
suis membre de la commission des
finances le RSTA revenu supplémentaire
temporaire d'activité qui a à bien des
égards a contribué à régler la crise de
l'été dernier et qui préfigurait le RSA
il apparaît cependant qu'il y a
des des tensions en tous les cas des un
risque d'impact sur les revenus de
compte tenu de la fiscalisation dont ce
RSTA peut-être l'objet et de son impact
éventuel sur le PPE et donc sur la prime
la PPE pardon et donc je souhaiterais
monsieur le Président que Madame le
Ministre puisse sur ce point nous
rassurer c'est un élément important euh
de ces débats de l'n de de ce début
d'année
ministre monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison de poser cette question parce que
je sais les inquiétudes concernant la
mise en application du RSTA je voudrais
simplement rappeler que le RSTA a été
mis en place au moment de la crise et
que dès le départ il a été proposé pour
assurer je dirais un complément de
revenu une mise en place d'une
prestation sociale il n'y a eu aucune
ambigué du gouvernement sur le fait que
le RSA était un RSA adapté et que
c'était une prestation sociale et qu'à
ce titre s'agissant d'une prestation
sociale il était aligné sur le régime
fiscal et social du RSA cela étant
aujourd'hui ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que se pose la question de la PPE
la prime pour l'emploi et que bon nombre
de nos compatriotes sont inquiets
concernant l'application de la PPE
aujourd'hui tous les efforts du
gouvernement sont concentrés sur la mise
en application du rsda je suis
intervenue moi-même en me rendant en
Guadeloupe auprès de la clée générale de
sécurité social pour m'assurer que dès
le mois de novembre nous soyez nous
soyons à au niveau de la cible qui est
attendue pour la Guadeloupe et pour
l'ensemble de l'outreem c'est-à-dire
qu'on puisse atteindre 200000
prestations aujourd'hui il est très
difficile de dire compte tenu du taux
d'imposition en outreem puisque vous
savez que vous avez un abattement sur
supplémentaire de 30 % c'està-dire 20 +
10 il est très difficile de connaître
aujourd'hui l'impact de la PPE sur le
RSTA donc ce que nous proposons c'est de
faire un bilan de la situation et de
rendre compte à la représentation
parlementaire dans 6 mois pour l'instant
les bénéficiaires vont percevoir les 100
€ qui correspondent au RSTA et nous
verrons par la suite l'implication de la
PPE ultérieurement voilà ce que je
voulais dire à la date d'aujourd'hui
merci
monsieur le Président
frima merci monsieur le Président je
dirais on a assistéc d'iger et Serge
Larcher ont été couverts de fleurs je
toujours un remord dans ces cas là c'est
de penser qu'on est à 10 jours de la
toussin et que là aussi c'est un endroit
où je dire il y a beaucoup de fleurs
dans les cimetières j'espère que votre
rapport aura un meilleur sort madame la
ministre ma question est la suivante
nous allons être saisis
d'un projet sur les modifications
institutionnelles concernant les
collectivités
territoriales mon propos n pasen parler
ici dans le même temps la Guyane et la
Martinique vont être saisi d'un
référendum 74 article 74 puis
éventuellement article
73 donc ils vont ils vont voter au
moment où il y a incertitude sur conseil
territorial pas conseil territorial on
nous dit que l'adaptation législative
sera fait pour la Guadeloupe le
Martinique et la Guyane par voie
d'ordonnance est-ce que vous pouvez me
le confirmer et est-ce que c'est une
manière de pour vous de traduire
immédiatement dans les faits les
félicitations que vous avez accordé au
travail parlementaire fait par l'arger
et d'icher puisqueil le Parlement n'aura
pas à ce moment-là à s'occuper euh de ce
phénomène or une modification
institutionnelle ça doit passer dans le
Parlement il n'est pas légitime de faire
des ordonnance et deuxièmement et je me
tourne aussi vers mes collègues de la
Réunion c'est une interrogation que j'ai
je vous en fais part euh si d'aventure
mais on ne peut pas euh je dirais être
sûr que le pire ne se produira pas si
d'aventure le conseil éditorial était
institué à la Réunion euh comme en
Guadeloupe comme en guadeloup je crois
que vous avez pas parfaitement compris
le sens de ma pensée mon cher collègue
hein je dirais le pire n'est jamais
exclu donc nous aurons je dirais je
prends les égambes de la Réunion et de
la godou puisqu'ils ne sont pas
concernés par le référendum de du 17
janvier nous aurons donc dans cette
hypothèse un territoire
unique une assemblée fait unique qui
aura à la fois conseiller général et
conseill si vous me permettez mon
monsieur le Président de m'expliquer
c'est je crains que vous ne puissiez
saisir toute la finesse de mon propos en
étant un peu perturbé donc nous aurons
une situation où il y aura de fait une
assemblée unique est-ce que ça ne
nécessiterait pas de consulter au titre
de la Constitution et telle est ma
question les populations puissent qu'il
se retrouverait avec une assemblée
unique alors que le
724 prévoit que que s'il y a
modification institutionnelle et sen a
une de taille les populations doivent
être consulté j'aimerais entendre madame
la ministre et sur le problème des
ordonnances et sur ce point particulier
madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur je vais
vous répondre par rapport effectivement
à la situation de ces territoires qui
n'ont pas la même évolution
institutionnelle la Réunion et le
sénateur Jean-Paul virapouet a rappelé
son attachement au droit commun donc la
réforme territoriale s'appliquera pour
la réunion pour les autres voilà non
parce que ça été confirmé aussi par les
élus au sens où il n'y a pas de
délibération du congrès qui réunit les
Conseil Général et le Conseil régional à
la date d'aujourd'hui donc en l'absence
de délibération c'est le droit commun
qui s'applique pour les autres
départements la Guyane et la Martinique
ont fait valoir une évolution
institutionnelle que nous organisons la
Guadeloupe s'est réunie aussi et la
Guadeloupe a demandé un délai
supplémentaire de 18 mois on ne peut pas
préjuger des résultats de la
consultation si la consultation donne
une évolution institutionnelle pour la
Martinique et la Guadeloupe ou et la
Guyane avec soit l'article 74 soit
l'article 73 avec une collectivité
unique le problème est réglé en revanche
si à ces deux questions nous avons un
nom il fallait quand même préserver les
intérêts de ces territoires et donc pour
gagner du temps nous avons pris le
principe d'une
ordonance qui permettra d'inscrire de
nouveau les collectivités dans le droit
commun puisque ça voudrait dire que en
ayant refusé l'évolution
institutionnelle elle sera elle souhaite
rester dans l'identité législative et je
voudrais ajouter pour terminer qu'il
faut pas peut-être dans le cas de la
collectivité unique faire une confusion
entre collectivité unique et
collectivité identique parce que ce
serait un regroupement euh je dirais des
des compétences des deux collectivités
département région au travers de ce
conseil territorial et on aurait pas
besoin d'une consultation au de nouveau
au regard de l'article 72 voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
Pignard vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué il y a un
instant les problèmes du logement social
mes collègues de l'Union centriste sont
effectivement préoccupés par cette
question la loi pour le développement
économique de l'outrem a voulu apporter
un certain nombre de réponses dans ce
domaine notamment en concentrant les
efforts financiers sur le logement
social par un nouveau mécanisme de
défiscalisation les textes d'application
sont sur le point d'être adopté mais
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
donner des précisions concrètes surtout
alors que les professionnels sont
particulièrement inquiets quant à cette
période de transition quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre pour permettre une
mise en œuvre effective et rapide de ces
nouvelles mesures de la loi dans le
secteur du
logement nous je signale aussi mais nous
en parlerons lors du débat budgétaire
que le projet de loi de finance 2010
prévoit une baisse des autorisations
d'engagement sur la ligne budgétaire
unique certes cette baisse est faible
0,25 % mais je ne crois pas que ce soit
un signal positif d'autant qu'il a
solennellement adopté dans la loi que la
ligne budgétaire unique reste le socle
du financement du logement social dans
les départements
d'outremer par ailleurs la mission
d'information a énuméré des points qui
restent à approfondir pour résoudre la
crise du logement par exemple sur les
paramètres de la ligne budgétaire unique
sur les normes et règles techniques qui
pèsent lourdement et souvent inutilement
sur les finances des bailleurs et des
promoteurs et puis il faudrait évoquer
aussi la question du foncier vous avez
fait allusion la mission propose une
solution innovante un droit au foncier
opposable c'est-à-dire une sorte de
droit de tirage des collectivités
locales sur certains terin de l'État en
vue de réalisation d'opération les
modalités restent à fixer mais que
pensez-vous de cette mesure donc qui
pourrait répondre localement à certains
besoins et qui pourrait avoir un intérêt
incitatif sur les services de l'État
parfois il faut bien le reconnaître peu
mobilisé sur la question enfin dernier
point la mission d'information faisait
également le constral de l'extrême
urgence en ce qui concerne l'habitat
insalubre et le récent rapport de notre
collègue député Serge lechimi conforte
cette analyse quelle mesure concrète là
aussi comptez-vous prendre pour
combattre enfin fortement cet habitat
indigne le ministre si la mission veut
intervenir à tout moment elle peut le
faire monsieur le sénateur sans dévoiler
les décisions qui vont prises qui vont
être prise dans le comité
interministérial de l'outreem parce que
vous en doutez que la question du
logement sera abordée je peux vous
apporter quelques précisions d'ors et
déjà vous dire qu'au niveau de la
défiscalisation il y a une volonté de
déconcentrer la gestion des dossier au
plan local pour permettre une plus
grande réactivité et qui a de la
possibilité aujourd'hui les décrets
d'application seront opérationnel je
l'ai dit dès le mois prochain donc on va
pouvoir utiliser toutes les possibilités
de l' lodéom à savoir soit la LBU soit
la LBU plus la défiscalisation soit la
défiscalisation ça c'est la première
chose sur les normes je sais
qu'effectivement le rapport a soulevé un
certain nombre d'interrogations à la
fois sur des normes environnementales je
note par ailleurs que dans le cadre de
l'habilitation il est possible pour les
collectivités de faire valoir cette
possibilité en demandant l'habilitation
ce qui permettrait de revoir les normes
et donc d'abaisser les coûts de
construction des logements sociaux en
outreemire donc c'est une voie à
explorer nous pouvons tout à fait le
faire aujourd'hui la Guadeloupe a cette
habilitation lors de mon déplacement je
n'ai pas me manqué de l'évoquer avec les
bailleurs sociaux donc il y a une piste
de travail alors sur le foncier certes
le rapport propose un droit opposable au
foncier je suis pas sûr que ce soit
forcément la bonne formulation
l'essentiel pour nous sur le foncier
c'est de maîtriser le foncier de faire
en sorte que le foncier ne soit pas un
frein au lancement de ces opération il y
a plusieurs possibilités qui ont déjà
été expérimenté avec notamment le frafu
dans le cadre du plan de relance nous
avons mis en place des conventions
d'action foncière dans certains
départements notamment à la Réunion à la
Guadeloupe ça
et je peux vous dire que c'est un succès
puisque ça permet de baisser
considérablement la participation des
collectivités il y a des pistes
aujourd'hui elles seront confortées
parce que nous savons qu'il faut agir à
la fois certes sur les
paramètres des opérations et en même
temps sur les paramètres de la LBU merci
monsieur le rapporteur sur les
paramètres de la LBU et en même temps
sur la question du foncier ces points
seront traités dans le cadre du comité
interministériel voilà
merci
monsieur le
rapporteur oui je me permets juste de
donner deux chiffres à à mon collègue là
en tant que
rapporteur au niveau budgétaire pour la
commission des finances sur la LBU je
pense qu'il y a pas de souci à se faire
il y avait une peur lorsqu'on a discuté
de la loi il y a quelques temps la lodum
en disant la lodum va finalement
conduire à abaisser la
laalbu et nous aurons de la
défiscalisation qui va j' dirais prendre
sur la LAALB donc la ligne budgétaire
unique en réalité lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres qui sont inscrits dans le
budget qu'on va vous présenter très
prochainement on s'aperçoit que la ligne
ne bouge pas puisque en
autorisation il y a
255,1 million contre
254,5 donc c'est vraiment une diminution
excessivement faible mais que par contre
les crédits de paiement augmentent et ce
qui compte sont les crédits de paiement
et les crédits de paiement passent de
200 6 à 210 millions soit 2 % de plus
donc il y a pas de souci particulier à
se faire pour l'année à
venir monsieur le Président oui je
voudrais juste compléter sur le problème
des logements sociaux les freins c'est
articulier il y a deux freais en fait il
y a d'abord le Freis dû à au problème de
l'indivision dans département mais en
particulier à la bartitique qu'il
faudrait régler avec la Ludum mais aucun
décret d'application n'est pris mais il
faudra trouver un moyen de régler ce
problème division de deuxè problème ce
n'est pas tant la le foncier qui n'est
pas disponible c'est la viabilisation et
du f l'aménagement du fonciers et quand
on sait que les communes et nous allons
le voir tout à l'heure sont exang et
bien on a une difficulté à sortir des
des du foncier pouvant être construit
par la suite le problème c'est d'abord
faire l'ffce sur FR lafue que vous avez
évoqué est loin de faire le le de faire
l'affire il faut il faudrait frchement
une action vigoureuse pour pouvoir
permettre de libérer non pas le foncier
mais Ctait viabilis et constr
voil vous soutiez ajouter quelque chose
si juste pour ajouter par rapport ce que
vient dire il y a aussi la question de
l'implantation dans nos territoires
d'établissement public fonciers voilà
donc vous le savez mieux que moi
merci
madamez la parole ma ch collègue
merci président euh non rapidement
euh cette mission a été décidée début
d'année enfin si je me souviens bien
c'était suite à la l'expression de la
crise parce que la crise date pas
seulement d'une année euh donc surveni
l'année passée début de cette année moi
ce que je souhaite j'ai cru comprendre
madame la ministre que euh un semblant
de pas calendrier mais d'un suivi euh
alors faut-il ne faudrait-il pas
imaginer
un calendrier de enfin faire des points
d'étapes euh
entre vous et nous
Sénat pour essayer de faire émerger au
fur et à mesure les propositions les
préconisations qu'on a fait là dans la
mission et aborder au fur et à mesure
mettre en débat les propositions parce
que c'est vrai le président va annoncer
qu des mesures le 6 septembre mais
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas voir au-delà et
donc essayer d'imaginer ce calendrier
pour faire des points d'étape
merciistre sénatrice il est vrai que la
question du suivi des décisions qui
seront prises sont très importantes j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure que nous
souhaitons être dans une réponse
concrète et donc de s'assurer que les
choses seront faites c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ors et déjà vous savez
qu'au niveau de chacun des territoire
les ateliers des États généraux vont
être transformés en des comités de suivi
parce que nous avons aussi ce devoir à
la fois pour tous ceux qui se sont
mobilisés dans le cadre de cette
consultation de faire des propositions
et à la fois vis-à-vis de la population
elle-même qui a participer à cette
consultation donc les modalités sont en
train d'être fixées j'ai noté aussi que
le président du Sénat a décidé au niveau
de votre mission de mettre une un comité
de suivi à des moments donnés si vous le
souz nous pouvons effectivement débattre
et travailler parallèlement pour
échanger par rapport à ces avancements
qu'à la fois vous conatai et que nous
aussi nous mettrons en place
merci Monsieur Leclerc mon chers
collègue pour 2
minutes monsieur le président madame la
ministre je voudrais que ce débat
d'aujourd'hui soit l'occasion pour nous
de faire un premier point donc sur la
question des surpensions des
fonctionnaires de l'État outremire
he cet avantage on le sait tous
sobrement baptisé indemnité temporaire
de résidence ou ITR consiste en une
majoration des pensions qui va de 35 à
75 % et que la cour des compte avait
dénoncé non seulement pour son caractère
inéquitable mais aussi pour ses abus et
ses fraudes au terme d'un marathon
législatif qui a duré au moins 5 années
cet ITR a fait l'objet l'an dernier
donc d'une réforme qu'on peut qualifier
complexe et aussi très progressive alors
je souhaite madame et bien vous poser
quelques questions assez
simples la première toutes les
dispositions réglementaires
d'application ont ell été
prise la deuxème o en sont les mesures
de contrôle que le législateur avait
précisément souhaité pour renforcer et
les rendre enfin
effectives
enfin quel est et quel sera le bilan
financier à court moyen et long terme de
cette réforme dégagera-t-elle quelques
moyens pour favoriser les priorités du
développement de
l'outreem en effet si je vous pose ces
question c'est que je suis à la
lecture du site internet de votre
ministère très lubitatif et entre autres
82 % vous affirmez des bénéficiaires
actuels de l'IT ne verront pas leur
indemnité modifié par la réforme qui ne
les concerne pas alors que penser de
l'effectivité d'une telle
réforme madame ensuite je redoute donc
cette réforme qui a été conçue avant la
grave crise financière que nous
traversons ne soit hlas qu'un coup d'épé
dans l'eau en effet rétrospectivement
bien on peut dire qu'elle apparaît d'une
faible portée pour ne pas dire
plus je rappelle que son calendrier
d'application est d'une lenteur
désespérant un tel délai
2028 nous semble et c'est un ehémisme
beaucoup trop long
l'itire
et c'est une majorité de nos
concitoyens qui la pererçoivent comme ça
est un avantage d'un autre temps
illégitime et qui doit disparaître le
plus vite possible enfin et est-il utile
de préciser que l'accroissement des
déficits sociaux consécutif à la crise
que nous traversons rend désormais
impossible toute perspective d'extension
des surpensions au territoire ultramarin
qui n'en bénéficient pas sur ce point
d'ailleurs la réforme que nous avons
voté apparaît là encore très ambigue
elle prévoit en effet un rapport au
gouvernement à ce sujet alors
madame quand est-il qu'en est-il donc de
ce rapport dont le contenu je l'espère
et bien sera publié pourra faire l'objet
d'un débat public en définitive chers
collègues je crois qu'il ne faut pas se
tromper si la réforme de l'itire que
nous avons voté ne devait pas en être
une le sujet sachez-le et bien sera sur
la table du rendez-vous de
2010 sur les retraites en effet comment
comment pourrions-nous demander à 25
millions d'actifs et 13 millions de
retraités de consentir à nouveaux
sacrifices pour sauver notre pacte
social si les surpensions perdurent
merci merci madame le
ministre monsieur sénateur tout d'abord
je voudrais vous rappeler que cette
réforme était une réforme difficile dans
le cadre de la la refondte générale des
politiques publiques l'outremaire a
fortement participé à la RGPP et l'ITR
en est un exemple mais vous le savez
cette réforme était d'autant plus
difficile qu'elle concernait d'un nombre
important d'Ultramarins et que mon
prédécesseur a eu le courage de porter
cette réforme jusqu'au bout ça je tenais
à vous le rappeler ce d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les dispositions
ont été prises mais il faut savoir que
le parti qui a été retenu pour amorcer
la ré forme était de faire en sorte
qu'elle intervienne sur le flux et que
donc il n'était pas question de remettre
en cause les retraites constaté donc
tant que nous sommes dans le stock on
peut comprendre aujourd'hui que les
effets ne soient pas ressentis
immédiatement et qu'il faudra plus de 20
ans pour y parvenir mais simplement
l'objectif il est là l'objectif on va
l'atteindre et je pense que le
gouvernement a eu le courage d'aller
jusqu'au bout de cette réforme qui
n'était pas simple à mener alors
s'agissant de la compagnie
je dirais des retraites qui avaient été
évoquées à l'époque lors du
débat ERC vert le ministre du budget
sera amené prochainement à rendre un
rapport à la représentation
parlementaire sur ce point et il y aura
bien évidemment sujet à échanger au vu
des informations qui seront portées dans
ce rapport merci merci
Madame oui monsieur le rapporteurés
oui juste quelques explications
complémentaires pour monsieur mon mon
collègue sénateur simplement je voudrais
quand même rappeler que on est arrivé à
cette réforme après des périodes
difficiles il a fallu de très nombreux
amendements du Sénat qui ont été refusés
au fil du temps et finalement c'est le
rapporteur général du budget qui a pu
glisser euh dans je sais plus dansi dans
le collectif budgétaire qui a pu glisser
un amendement qui a permis de commencer
à faire évoluer le système de façon
courageuse comme vous l'avez dit Madame
le Ministre alors simplement je voudrais
rappeler sur les chiffres quand on
regarde les courbes bien sûr c'est pas
des courbes extraordinaire puisque on
continue à avoir une progression du coût
au fil des années puisque l'on a
simplement je dirais atténué les
conditions d'entrée et plafonner les
conditions d'entrée ce qui veut dire que
les sommes versées chaque année
continuent à augmenter encore pendant un
certain temps et que ça n'est qu'à
partir de 2028 qu'on commencera
probablement avoir les les sommes
diminué mais le le tableau que vous
pourrez lire avec je pense beaucoup de
plaisir et qui vous remonteront le moral
dans le rapport qu'on sortira lors de
l'analyse budgétaire et bien fait
ressortir que si on était à 270 millions
en 206 on sera à 350 millions en 2010 à
peu près hein donc c'est une progression
qui à terme va
s'inverser président Larcher
juste une précision euh c'est pour la
clarté du débat dire que les
départements d'outrem de du côté
Amérique Martin gu guyan ne n'ont jamais
bénéficié d'ITR et par conséquent ne
demande absolument rien Conant l'ITR
peut-être parce qu'on y vit moins
longtemps dans Cees département donc il
pas de retraite merci Claude LZ a
demandé la parole merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre je
souhaite revenir sur le problème du
foncier
notamment pour la Martinique on nous dit
souvent que si on ne nous accorde pas
plus de LBU c'est parce que de toute
façon on pourrait pas consommer parce
qu'il y a pas de foncier alors on a déjà
dit tout à l'heure qu'en fait ce qui
manque c'est du foncier viabilisé alors
bien sûr l'État
participe dans le cadre du fofu à au
financement de la viabilisation mais il
y a un problème qui se pose qui est
celui de la la conditionnalité hein de
la règle de conditionnalité dans dans le
le partage de l'intervention entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales les collectivités
territoriales doivent intervenir au
moins à hauteur de 20 % de la différence
entre la charge foncière réelle et la
une charge foncière de référence alors
contte tenu de la situation que l'on a
évoqué he très largement aujourd'hui
concernant les les collectivités
territoriales on se rend bien compte que
si on veut avancer il faut fa que l'État
fasse un effort le conseil général en
Martinique a été la seule collectivité
pratiquement à portter à bout de bras la
part des des 20 % il est d'ailleurs
monté beaucoup plus à 30 % à un moment
donné nous avons consacré plus de
7lions7 d'euros entre 2000 et 2006 à
cela et nous venons de débloquer 1 1,7
million d'euros pour aider à sortir des
opérations mais nous sommes pratiquement
à la limite de nos possibilité al ma
question c'est le gouvernement peut-il
accepter puisqu'on a beaucoup parlé de
d'adaptation il paraît que c'est c'est
c'est vraiment très très simple he si
j'en crois mon collègue mon collègue vir
poulet et là on n pas besoin du du
traité de Lisbonne on a on n pas besoin
de demander une habilitation on n pas
besoin que les décrets de la lodéum
sortent c'est quelque chose de très
simple le préfet de martinque fait
remonter la demande côté administration
nous avons à de multiples ise demander
cette chose très simple supprimer cette
règle de la conditionnalité de manière
qu'on puisse ajuster de part et d'autres
et selon les situations et pour être
être le plus conciliant possible je je
demande peut-on supprimer cette règle
même pour une durée limitée le temps que
nous traversions la crise et que les
choses changent avec toutes les mesur
que l'on nous a annoncé
aujourd'hui Madame le
Ministre
monsieur le sénateur vous vous posez une
vraie question sur la conditionnalité
vous savez que c'est la règle de 20 % de
participation des collectivité sur les
opérations des efforts ont déjà été
faits puisque vous avez indiqué
notamment travers du frafu et aussi la
convention d'action financière de
foncière pardon qui permet de réduire la
participation des collectivités de 20 %
à 10 %. on a bien conscience
qu'aujourd'hui ce système constitue un
frein pour les opérations je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprise ce point sera
largement pris en compte je ne peux pas
aller aujourd'hui plus loin parce que
vous convenez que le débat se situe en
amont du comité interministériel de
l'outreem tout n'est pas complètement
bouclé mais ce point sera abordé très
largement voilà merci Madame le Ministre
Colette kodicelli a demandé la
parole oui oui merci madame la
présidente Madame le Ministre la loi
portant réforme de l'hôpital qui a été
promulgué le 21 juillet dernier vous
l'avez d'ailleurs évoqué tout à l'heure
dans vos propos doit permettre à l'offre
de santé sur les territoires ultramarins
comme d'ailleurs en en métropole d'être
mieux coordonné plus efficient d'une
qualité accru tout ceci bien évidemment
dans le cadre d'une de contrainte
financière
réelle cependant si j'ai voulu insister
c'est sur le point des des du fait qu'il
existe des spécificités des régions
ultramarines qui justifie un
accompagnement tout à fait particulier
en matière de santé je pense par exemple
au en particulier en en aux conséquences
de certains risques naturels comme les
cyclones les tremblements de terre à
l'insularité à l'éloignement de la de la
métropole ou encore à certaines
pathologies tout à fait particulières
aux zones tropicales comme la
drpanocytose le le diabète ou certains
cancers de la prostate alors ce que je
souhaitais madame euh la ministre
c'était que vous nous rassuriez que vous
puissiez nous nous dire dans quelle
mesure ces particularités sanitaires des
départements d'outremer seront prises en
compte dans le cadre euh du plan Hôpital
2012 présenté par Xavier Bertrand à
l'époque ministre de la santé comme dans
le plan santé outremère dont vous nous
avez parlé tout à l'heure je vous
remercie merci Madame la
Ministre
alors bien évidemment euh cette question
relèverait plutôt d'e réponse que Rosine
Bachelot devrait vous apporter ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans
le plan de santé autremère tel qu'elle
l'a présenté aux Antill les questions
que vous évoquez qui concernent
notamment les risques naturels sont
prises en compte puisque un programme
important de réhabilitation des
établissements hospitaliers est prévu et
c'est dans ce cadre qu'à titre d'exemple
l'hôpital le CHU de poapite va être
reconstruit et ce qui représente une
enveloppe non néglige en ce qui concerne
concerne aussi les maladies
particulières qui concernent outre mè
ces dispositions sont aussi dans le plan
de santé puisque il y a un plan
trèpanocytose qui est prévu et d'autres
mesures qui concernent le plan santé
outremè va répondre et elles seront
confortées à l'occasion du comité
interministériel de l'outremè notamment
en ce qui concerne la formation la
recherche et dans bien de domaines merci
Daniel raou a demandé la
parole merci merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais rebondir sur une des
propositions de la mission sénatoriale
qui avait d'ailleurs proposé la création
d'une Maison des richesses des Outremers
un lieu de meilleure connaissance de
leur spécificité et surtout de la valeur
ajoutée qu'elle apporte à notre pays or
le 6 octobre 2009 le ministre de la
Culture et de la Communication Monsieur
Frédéric mteran a décidé de créer une
mission permanente destinée à valoriser
les richesses culturelles de l'utremer
en vue notamment de contribuer au
développement économique et social de
ces territoirees et de la confier à
Monsieur Michel colardel conservateur
général du patrimoine un rapport d'étape
est d'ailleurs attendue pour la fin du
mois de janvier
2010 ma question madame la ministre
concerne le périmètre la méthode les
moyens de cette mission et pourquoi
d'ailleurs le secrétariat d'État à
l'outrem n'est-il pas le maître d'œuvre
de cette
initiative si je me
fie aux compétences de la personne
responsable de la mission j'ai peur que
ceci se restregne aux valeurs
culturelles avec un grand C et non pas
prendre l'ensemble des valeurs des
richesses de l'outrer et ceci m'inquiète
quand je pense en particulier à toutes
les valeurs des qui se trouvent dans les
lagons dans la faune dans la flore et
qu'on s'en tienne simplement un
patrimoine ou alors à des œuvres
littéraires et je crois que l'outremire
a bien d'autres richesse à nous faire
partager et je je je crains que Monsieur
le conservateur général du patrimoine
s'arrête simplement à des considérations
qui à mon avis d'abord ne seraient trop
restreintes la deuxè question
concerne
comment cette mission va travailler en
particulier avec les ultramarins et
leurs représentants c'est une question
quand même je pense que les élus de ces
territoires ont sans doute une
connaissance assez complète des
richesses et comment compte-il aussi
travailler avec les assemblées
parlementaires et faire en sorte que
l'initiative qui avait été soulevé dans
ce rapport puisse avoir une suite merci
madame la
ministre monsieur sénateur vous avez
soulevé la question d'une meilleure
prise en compte de l'identité culturelle
des outremè et à la fois de la
valorisation des atouts et des
potentialités de l'outremè c'est un
sujet crucial puisqu'il fait partie d'un
axe fort des points qui ont été soulevés
au moment de la crise sociale où la
question d' l'identité était au cœur des
préoccupations des ultramarins donc vous
imaginez bien qu'à l'occasion des
décisions qui seront prises cette
dimension sera retenue s'agissant de la
mission dont vous faites état je ne peux
que me féliciter que le ministre de la
Culture s'approprie la question de
l'outremè le secrétariat d'État à
l'outremè n'a pas vocation à se
substituer à l'ensemble des compétences
et des missions des autres ministères et
à ce titre je trouve
que les différents ministres devraient
encore mieux traiter la question à
l'utre maire à chaque fois qu'une
question se pose au plan national et
bien évidemment sur cette mission qui ne
reflète pas la prise en compte
uniquement de ce patrimoine mais bien
évidemment il n'y aura d'autres éléments
complémentaires le ministre aura
naturellement le soin d'associer tous
les ultramarins aussi bien les
territoires que mon secrétariat et je
serai amené à le rencontrer très
prochainement pour débattre certes de la
mission mais d'autres points qui
concernent l'outreemèire notamment
l'implantation d'un certain nombre de
centres culturel en outrem qui pose
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'une plus
forte implication de son ministère donc
je ne peux que me féliciter de l'action
du ministre de la culture dans ce
domaine alain
GOURNAC madame madame le ministre je
vais vous parler d'emploi plus
exactement de chômage puisque vous savez
que dans les domes le chômage est deux à
trois fois plus important qu' métropole
atteignant près du quart de la
population active de chaque département
20,6 en Guyane 24,5 à la Réunion et
quand on regarde le taux de chômage
moyen en métropole c'est 7 et demi et le
problème le plus grave c'est que le
chômage touche particulièrement les
jeunes soit près de la moitié des jeunes
actifs de 15 à 24 ans contre 20 % au
niveau
national je considère que cette
situation est d'une extrême gravité et
une action de très grandendre ampleur
est nécessaire pour endiguer ce fléo je
dis bien ce fléo l'État doit s'engager à
mobiliser davantage de moyens pour agir
sur les causes profondes du chômage
massif des jeunes et en particulier
l'absence ou l'insuffisance de
qualification alors madame le ministre
voilà la question que je vous pose je
voudrais vous parler des contrats aidés
outremè est-ce que ces contrats aidés
outremè vont continuer en 2010 car dans
cette situation qui est particulièrement
préoccupante particulièrement dégradée
de l'emploi il faut absolument avoir des
réactions qui soient des réactions
fortes pour sortir
ces Français du chômage et en
particulier ces
jeunes merci Madame le
Ministre pour traiter la question du
chômage qui est une préoccupation
essentiel en outre ma notamment le
chômage des jeunes je crois qu'il faut
agir à deux niveaux il faut agir sur le
plan économique c'est bien la portée de
la loi pour le développement
d'outreemère qui a été votée au
Parlement au mois d'avril
puisqueeffectivement le souci du
gouvernement a été de concentrer tout
l'effort et tout le soutien aux
entreprises dans des zones d'activité
dont nous savons pertinemment qu'ell
sont créateurs de richesse c'est le
développement durable c'est les
nouvelles technologies où nous savons av
demain qui a un un vivier pour créer des
emplois demain donc il faut agir sur euh
il faut agir sur le secteur économique
il faut aussi encourager à l'emploi par
les exonérations de charges même si
aujourd'hui je sais que ça peut soulever
des débats il faut maintenir l'outil de
défiscalisation qui n'est pas en
outreemère une niche fiscale mais qui
soutient le secteur économique même si
aujourd'hui je sais que ça soulève un
débat mais ça permet de maintenir des
activités et donc de préserver l'emploi
et par ailleurs il faut agir aussi en
direction des populations concernées ça
passe par le retour à l'emploi et les
contrats aidés sont une façon de
permettre ce retour à l'emploi donc je
considère qu'aujourd'hui ces contrats
aidés doivent être maintenus c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
l'enveloppe est maintenue simplement il
faut avoir à l'esprit que les contrats
aidés dans dans le secteur public
peuvent générer des difficultés pour les
collectivités par rapport à la charge
que ça supporte ultérieurement cont tenu
des frais assédiques que les
collectivités devront supporter donc
aussi on est dans cette difficulté mais
au-delà de la question effectivement de
l'emploi il y a toute la question
aujourd'hui de la formation et sur la
formation je crois qu'il faut concentrer
il faut avoir une politique beaucoup
plus cohérente il faut mettre en
relation les plans de formation avec les
débouchés qui existent sur le territoire
il s'agit pas de faire de la formation
pour de la formation parce qu'on crée de
la frustration chez nos jeunes
aujourd'hui il faut qu'il y ait une
véritable adéquation entre la formation
qui est dispensée dans les centres de
formation en outreem avec les besoins de
ces territoire or aujourd'hui nous
savons que nous sommes encore très loin
de cette approche en tout cas le
gouvernement va l'encourager et puis
aussi un dernier élément qui est
important pour nous on constate en
nreemre une augmentation forte de
l'ilérisme il faudra que là-dessus nous
ayons des mesures très concrètes parce
que ça c'est aussi une source
d'exclusion de nos jeunes et si nos
jeunes sont exclus je pense que demain
nous allons recréer des conditions pour
avoir une nouvelle tension sociale ce
que nous ne voulons pas le rapporteur
monsur rapporteur
oui je voudrais juste parce que il y a
la formation il y a un certain nombre de
sujets bien évidemment l'orientation
jeis juste donner un exemple qui m'a
beaucoup frappé pendant la mission on a
écouté le le recteur à la Réunion qui
nous a dit que chaque année il y avait
dans l'éducation nationale 1000
embauches turnover 1000 embauches que
sur les 1000 embauches ben ils venaient
tous de métropole il y en a 900 qui
viennent de métropole et il y en a 100
qui viennent de la Réunion alors qu'il y
a suffisamment de sorties à la Réunion
euh de gens qui ont bac + 5 et qui
espèrent rentrer dans l'éducation
nationale bon la problématique c'est
bien évidemment dans les concours il y a
beaucoup de gens de la métropole qui
avec une surrémunération de 1,53 enfin
53 % sont quand même intéressés à les
passer euh euh faire passer un temps à
la Réunion bon euh et bien évidemment
bah les jeunes qui sont sur place qui
ont moins d'ancienneté moins de
compétences moins de bouteilles entre
guillemets euh on plus de difficulté à
obtenir le résultat au concours et
finalement il voit des métropolitains
passer devant je vous fais pas de dessin
pour l'ambiance que ça peut créer la
déception des jeunes sur le terrain donc
c'est pour ça qu'on pense qu'il doit
pouvoir y avoir une réflexion à ce
niveau-là alors on n pas la solution
mais on a quand même des pistes
intéressantes si on dit qu'il vaut mieux
savoir le créole pour pouvoir renseigner
là-bas déjà ça met une petite frontière
quelque part bon ENF je pense qu'il y a
une petite réflexion à
faire merci George patient
madame la ministre dans votre
intervention vous avez été
particulièrement muette sur les demandes
de dotation en faveur des collectivités
territorial de Guyane et également en
faveur d'un déplafonnement de la
dotation superficielle bon j'espère que
le 6 novembre nous serons davantage
rassurés sur ces deux points ma question
va surtout porté sur la visibilité des
outromèes dans dans les médias un sujet
traité également dans le rapport du
Sénat comment le secrétariat d'État
compte-il agir pour accroître cette
visibilité quand on sait que le
principal média des outremes RFO
rencontte de plus en plus de difficultés
pour remplir ses missions de service
public et pourtant son rattachement à
France Télévision réalisé courant 2004
avait pour objectif au dire du ministre
de la Culture et de la Communication du
moment de garantir le développement
ainsi que la pérennité de l'audiovisuel
public ultramarin pour l'URE seul France
e passer du statut de chaîne de l'outrem
à celui de la diversité semble et encore
retenir l'attention de la direction
centrale madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous donner des assurances
que l'organisation de l'ensemble des
chaînes de télévision publique à travers
une entreprise commune sera
effectivement synonyme de développement
et non de régression tant pour les
cultures d'REM que pour les salariés de
RFO en clair les stations régionales de
RFO vont-elles enfin disposer d'un
budget de production spécifique aux
identités culturelles de chaque
territoire les salariés ultramarins de
RFO vont-ils bénéficier de manière
égalitaire de la mobilité au sein des
autres chaînes enfin ces CADES
originaires de nos régions vont-ils
exister au niveau de l'encadrement
supérieur de l'entreprise commune
sachant que ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui aucun d'entre eux ne
siégeant dans le comité exécutif de
l'entreprise ministre
monsieur le sénateur ne considérez pas
que j'ai été volontairement muette j'ai
simplement illustré dans mes propos
quelques exemples et j'ai indiqué que
bien évidemment je laissais au débat la
possibilité qu'on puisse aller plus loin
dans les questions donc s'agissant de la
dotation dont vous parlez pour la
guuyane ce que je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui on a bien conscience que la
situation de la guuyane et aussi celle
de Mayotte n'est pas comparable avec les
autres départements d'outremè et qu'à ce
titre ti il est tout à fait normal que
l'État se pose la question d'un
accompagnement particulier pour la
Guyane et pour les collectivités de la
Guyane c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui parce que cette
réflexion est en cours s'agissant de la
question de la visibilité aujourd'hui il
y a une convention d'objectif et de
moyens du CSA pour prendre en compte
cette visibilité au travers de nos
chaînes de télévision nous espérons
pouvoir aller plus loin nous engageons
un travail à ce sujet mais pour ce qui
est de RFO convenez avec moi que nous n
sommes dans une question qui relève de
la gestion à l'interne de France
Télévision et je crois que cette
question devrait plutôt l'avir avec mon
collègue frédéc mitteran qui peut à ce
moment-là examiner plus en profondeur je
dis bien que le ministre de l'outremère
n'est pas le premier ministre des
outremèes il doit travailler en lien
avec l'ensemble de ses collègues sur des
questions très techniques et celle que
vous posez en ce qui concerne RFO
nécessite effectivement un rapprochement
avec le ministère de la Culture monsieur
le rapporteur
oui ah très bien madame la ministre je
vais vous poser une petite question et
vous supposez que qu'elle tras à l' de
maire je pensais ne pas vous la poser
aujourd'hui mais j'ai une émission ce
soir en télévision et les maires je sais
vous écoutent en ce moment donc comment
vous allez me répondre vous allez le
répondre en même temps le trit de maire
vous savez pour ceux qui le savent pas
c'est une c'est un une enveloppe
prélevée sur nos importations et sur la
production locale et qui vient financer
essentiellement les budgets des communes
et budget des des des régions or le 3 de
mai lors de notre passage à Bruxelles
euh nous avons constaté que le
commissaire n'avait reçu un rapport
venant de chez vous et que ce rapport à
mi étape puisque doctber esté jusqu'à
2014 devrait montrer la pertinence du
dispositif visant à développer l'emploi
l'activité l'emploi donc les entreprises
et cetera et ce rapport ne prouve
absolument rien il serait totalement
vide nous attons confié et que si cela
devait rester en l'état leroit de merire
disparaîtrait en 2014 et vous comprenez
les mois des maires attendant de tel tel
discours par conséquent aujourd'hui la
question est de savoir si l'État
entend envoyer un autre rapport à
Bruxelles montrant effectivement la
pertinence de dispositif ou bien si l'
l'État a pensé a une une solution une un
financement pour se substituer à l'roit
de maire alors j'ai beaucoup entendu des
choses je vous rappelle madame la
ministre que les autres rupes canari
Mader et et assort qui ont un dispositif
équivalent ont déposé le rapport qui est
très
probant ce qui nous a un peu surpris
c'est que nous n'avions pas n'arions pas
à apportter à donner un document qui qui
nous mettre qui nous rassure ça c'est la
première chose deuxème chose c'est que
comme vous le savez du suite par la
suite de la crise et la crise additionné
aux événements de début d'année le M a
connu un
affaissement à la Martinique en
particulier a des AG département de TR m
et le manque à gagné est de l'ordre de
35 à à 35 à 50 35 à 40 %. quand on sait
que c cetteit de mer finance à hauteur
de 50 même 65 % les budgets des communes
les budgets de fonctionnement commune on
comprend dans très bien quelle
difficulté les maires auront à financer
à terminer l'année je précise que lectit
de maire sert surtout à payer les
salaires d'assurer les chares la charge
salariale dans les communes par
conséquent madame la ministre est-ce que
l'état de ce côté-là envisage apporter
un soutien euh au différentes communes
ou bien si l'État qui a un dispositif
Doct qui s'appelle fond de garantie de
garantie hein mais qui ne garantit
absolument rien qui garantit quand ça
augmente et quand ça diminue il n a pas
de garantie du tout personne donc si
l'Étap entend apporter une solution on a
concret concrète du moins aux communes
de façon à leur permettre de terminer
l'année et de fêter la Noël je vous
remercie merci André
Villier ah madame la ministre voulez
répondre Madame le Ministre
je voudrais répondre effectivement sur
la question de l'ocroit de mer vous avez
raison de dire qu'aujourd'hui l'ocroit
de mer c'est une recette essentielle
pour les collectivités l'outre j'ai
aussi indiqué qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse au-delà de l'oroit de mer ça
veut pas dire que je ne soutiens pas une
position qui consiste à pérenniser
l'octroit de mer simplement vous savez
avec moi que il faudra qu'on justifie
auprès de Bruxelles les retombées de cet
octroit de mer à la fois cert par
rapport aux ressources des collectivité
ça n'y a aucune difficulté mais sur les
conséquences bénéfiques des productions
locales or aujourd'hui quand je regarde
les différentes listes ABC et le
différentiel j'ai l'occasion de le faire
hier pour partir à Bruxelles je peux
comprendre la difficulté à établir ce
rapport en direction de la commission
pour que la Commission soit convaincue
que nous avons intérêt à maintenir ce
dispositif donc moi ce que je vous
propose monsieur le sénateur c'est que
nous puissions lancer une étude en lien
avec les collectivités locales parce que
vous savez que c'est les régions qui
fixent les taux de l'octroit de mer et
que ce titre elles détiennent toutes les
informations qui nous permettront
d'avoir une analyse conjointe qui soit
en faveur du maintien de cet outil
fiscal en direction de l'outre-em ça
c'est la première chose sur la baisse de
l'ctw mer vous savez qu'elle est
étroitement liée au phénomène que nous
avons connu cet hiver à la fois dans une
volonté pour baiss pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat nous avons baissé les
collectivités ont pris le parti de
baisser le octroit de mer et en même
temps du fait du ralentissement de
l'activité économique les marchandises
ne rentront plus sur le port de
Martinique et de for et de pointapit
forcément vous avez une baisse aussi de
l'octroi de mer donc on a bien
conscience que ça aura des effets très
désastreux sur les finances des
collectivités il y a des dispositifs qui
existent le plan cocarde vous le
connaissez aussi la restructuration
financière qui peut être envisagé en
lien avec lafd nous serons
particulièrement attentifs pour faire en
sorte que ces deux dispositifs font
fctionne et soutiennent pendant cette
période difficile les collectivités
d'outrem merci André
Villier permettez-moi madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la mission d'information
monsieur le rapporteur de cette mission
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs de goûter cet instant
privilégié celui de la première
intervention dans cette prestigieuse
enceinte pour le nouveau sénateur que je
suis cet instant constituera pour moi un
inoubliable souvenir et j'oserai teinter
d'exotisme pour vous mes chers collègues
je forme le veœux qu'il soit l'occasion
de se remémorer votre première
intervention euh sous les riches ors du
Sénat c'est
donc un parlementaire j'y viens
métropolitain qui s'intéressera à un
sujet relevant
d'agriculture et si je n'ai pas eu
moi-même l'occasion de traiter sur place
d'une question hélas commune au
département d'outremer et à la métropole
je veux dire la régression des surfaces
agricoles je souhaite néanmoins madame
la ministre vous interroger sur la
situation dans les départements
d'outremer en effet les l'évolution de
la surface agricole utile est
inquiétante dans ces départements et
plus particulièrement dans les
Antilles avec une chute de près de 25 %
en 15
ans quelle mesur le gouvernement
compte-il prendre dans ce domaine
éventuellement via la loi de
modernisation agricole qui devrait être
discutée au Parlement en 2010 afin
d'assurer un véritable plan de
restauration de l'espace agricole
merci
merci alors la
parole madame la
ministrez
effectivement la question des surfaces
agricole utile pose une difficulté en
outreem puisqu'on assiste à une baisse
considérable de ces surfaces et ça ne
permet pas la diversification agricole
et ça ne permet pas de maintenir
l'activité agricole qui est essentielle
parce que vous vous savez aussi que le
gouvernement appuie fortement cette
diversification agricole dans le cadre
de sa politique d'un développement
endogène et d'un soutien de la
production agricole et donc ça passe de
la production locale donc ça passe par
le maintien de l'activité agricole
conscient effectivement de cette
diminution importante des surfaces
agricoles nous travaillons avec le
ministère de l'Agriculture pour
envisager un texte qui permettra de
limiter et d'éviter ces déclassements
aujourd'hui qui font que cette surface
agricole diminue
considérablement merci monsieur le
rapporteur
oui euh je voulais dire à mon à mon
collègue que dans dans le rapport page
160 on donne effectivement les surfaces
avec leur diminution surface agricole
mais une des propositions que que l'on
fait c'est d'engager un véritable plan
de restructuration ou de restauration
plutôt de l'espace agricole en
augmentant la surface agricole utile la
SAU et à la suite des différents
entretiens qu'on a eu sur place alors
vous remarquerez d'ailleurs dans le
rapport que chaque département entre 25
et 40000 hectares à peu près c'est quand
même des chiffres assez proches et on
est persuadé que dans bien des cas on
doit pouvoir arriver à augmenter de
façon très sensible les surfaces utiles
en restructurant les territoires en
utilisant des parties de territoire qui
ne le sont pas actuellement on a
rencontré des personnalités locales qui
nous ont confirmé qu'il ne devrait pas y
avoir de difficultés particulières en
plus l'état souvent possède je parle pas
de la la Guyane là parce que là c'est
une évidence puis j'auris pas provoqué
mes de collègue mais l'état possède bien
souvent des surfaces qui doivent être
récupérables et pouvoir être mises en
culture merci alors la parole est à
Jacques
Gillot comment il Sapp madame la
ministre permettez-moi de revenir sur le
problème du chômage et singulièrement du
drame du chômage des jeunes dans les
domes la mission sénatoriale a préconisé
la mise en place d'un véritable plan
Marchal pour combattre ce fléo en effet
le chômage touche massivement les jeunes
des domes près de 50 % des jeunes actifs
15 24 ans sont au chômage contre 20 % au
niveau national parmi les CAES identifié
arrivve en premier rang le faible taux
de qualification or les taux de sortie
sont diplôme du système éducatif sont
très élevés l'insertion des jeunes sur
le marché du travail constitue bien pour
le département ultra marin un enjeu
spécifique de 26 % à 58 % des jeunes on
quitté en 2007 le système scolaire sans
diplôme je m'interroge donc sur les
modalités selon
laquelle selon lesquelles plutôt le plan
jeune annoncé le 29 septembre dernier
par le Président de la République sera
décliné dans ces département notamment
en ce qui concerne le RSA
jeune alors madame la ministre
ministre
effectivement la question de l'emploi
des jeunes reste essentiel je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure donc il faut qu'on puisse
agir sur la qualification la formation
ça c'est une chose au niveau des jeunes
qui sont complètement loin de l'emploi
et de la société vous savez qu'on a un
dispositif qui est celui du SMA il ne
suffit pas en soi mais c'est une
approche il y en aura d'autres parce
qu'il faut notamment agir sur le cur
scolaire et en même temps il faut agir
sur la formation ce point sera vu mais
en ce qui concerne votre demande
d'appliquer le RSA jeune la question
elle est très simple il n'y aura pas de
cumul entre le RSC qui est un RSA adapé
et le RSA puisque le RSA jeune c'est une
extension du RSA on ne va pas faire
cumuler sur les territoires les deux
dispositif ça avait été clairement
indiqué par le gouvernement au moment de
la mise en place du RSCA en revanche
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il se pose la
question de l'application du RSCA
pendant 3 ans parce qu'il est lié comme
vous le savez à un accord professionnel
l'accord Bido mais s'il y a des voix
aujourd'hui pour faire en sorte que le
RSA devienne la solution pour l'outrem
car nous considérons comme vous que
c'est peut-être la solution la plus
juste et qui réponde mieux aux
préoccupations des ultramarins je l'ai
dit lors de mon déplacement aux Antilles
je suis tout à fait disposé à vous
accompagner monsieur le
sénateur merci Madame la Ministre alors
c'est à François Noël
buffet je n'is pas dire monsieur le
Président que je désespérais monsieur le
Président Madame le
Ministre je voudrais aborder un sujet
qui n'a pas été abordé me semble-t-il
jusqu'à maintenant en tous les cas je
n'étais pas au début de des débats je
vous prie de m'excuser qui est celui de
l'immigration clandestine l'actualité
récente et l'actualité maoraaise en
particulier vient de nous rappeler
toutes les tout le drame que draîne
l'immigration clandestine en 2006 le
Sénat par l'intermédiaire de du
rapporteur que j'étais avait commis un
un document un rapport de commission
d'enquête sur ce thème-là au terme du
rapport au terme duquel nous avions fait
45 recommandations dont certaines
d'ailleurs il faut le dire ont été
reprises soit par le texte de 2007 soit
par le texte de le texte 2006 ou le
texte ensuite voté en en 2007 pour
autant il me semble utile que vous
puissiez peut-être ce soir de façon
évidemment pas très exhaustive mais
faire le point sur l'évolution à la fois
des moyens de contrôle mise en place par
l'État également de la lutte contre le
travail illégal qui est un sujet
évidemment qui est la source ou une des
sources de l'immigration clandestine et
enfin sans doute ce qui peut représenter
me semble-t-il une façon de percevoir
une solution les coopérations avec les
pays voisins comment celles-ci se
sont-elles mises en place d'ailleurs se
sont-elles mises en place ou en tous les
cas sont-elles en train de se mettre en
place merci
Madame merci madame la ministre je vous
en
prie alors la question de l'immigration
NRE une préoccupation du
gouvernement je voulais vous dire que
notamment à Mayotte les moyens ont été
renforcé de manière considérable en tête
j'ai les chiffres rien que pour la PAF
c'est 290 % d'augmentation c'est pour
vous dire le nombre de fonctionnaires
qui ont été mis à disposition pour la
Guadeloupe il y a une augmentation de 20
% en Guyane c'est 40 % des effectifs de
la PAF mais s'agissant plus
particulièrement de Mayotte on a une
cellule de coordination opérationnelle
gendarmerie douane ainsi que la PAF et
la marine et qu'il est prévu un 4e radar
la Guyane vous savez que l'opération
Harpic contribue à limiter l'immigration
sur ce territoire à Saint-Martin il y a
un local de rétention administrative qui
a été créé en 2008 vous voyez bien que
la question de l'immigration est bien
prise en compte puisque les moyens sont
renforcés en outre-mer sachant
qu'aujourd'hui le nombre de recondu
outre-em est exactement du même niveau
que le nombre de reconduites au plan de
la France hexagonal puisque nous sommes
à 25000 reconduites en outreemè à
comparé au 25000 de la France hexagonale
mais c'est vrai que la lutte de contre
l'immigration passera aussi par la lutte
contre le travail clandestin et c'est
bien pour la raison pour laquelle le RSA
peut-être aussi une solution s'il était
appliqué en outr-emère ça permettra
effectivement de limiter ce travail
clandestin et aussi ça passe par un
renforcement de la politique de
coopération ce qui a été amorcé au
niveau de Mayotte avec la mise en place
d'un groupe technique de haut niveau qui
doit permettre le rapprochement entre
Mayotte et les Comand mais
qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu des résultats
de la départementalisation alors que
nous avions amorcé le travail travail et
qui avait eu déjà des approches entre
les délus de ces deux ces deux
territoires aujourd'hui c'est un point
mort mais nous espérons bien relancer ce
groupe technique de haut niveau pour
permettre cette
coopération la parole est à la
présidente Michel
André monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues une des
propositions du rapport sénatorial
concerne la visibilité des outr mère euh
comment le secrétariat d'État compte-il
agir pour accroître celle-ci dans les
médias
des contacts ou des engagements ont-ils
été pris dans ce sens avec le Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel en
particulier la création d'une Agence
nationale et d'agence régional pour la
promotion des cultures ultramarines
associant les collectivités locales et
les associations solution qui
permettrait de produire des programmes
de plus large diffusion a été proposé
par la Mission comptez-vous la mettre
très prochainement à l'étude madame la
ministre madame la
ministre sur la question de la
visibilité des autres mèes je vais pas
me répéter je viens de le dire tout à
l'heure notamment par rapport à la
convention qui existe entre avec le CSA
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il y a un
fort besoin du milieu culturel pour la
création de cette agence ça fait partie
des propositions qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'étude c'est à Catherine
procaia prendre la parole merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre dans le
rapport que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
euh sur le chord descones nous avons mis
l'accent sur la pollution des eaux
continentales et des milieux marins
euh risque qui nous a paru euh avéré eu
égard au prélèvement effectué par
l'ifffreemer récemment le ministère de
l'Agriculture a interdit par arrêté
préfectoral la pêche en Martinique et je
crois en Guadeloupe je pourrais
m'estimer contente puisque cela signifie
que notre rapport a été lu mais pour ma
part il n'a pas il a peut-être été lu
mais il n'a pas été compris en effet
avec jean-ve ledéo nous préconisions de
réaliser davantage de prélèvements sur
les poissons avant de prendre une
décision je veux dire à mes collègues
qu'il y a eu 144 poissons étudiés et
prélevé en Guadeloupe et 244 en
Martinique en 2 ans ça ne fait quand
même pas une population très importante
sans compter que ces poissons ont eu des
résultats très contestés et quand un
tazard est contrôlé est positif on n'est
pas dans le Tour de France mais on est
bien dans une dans une course aussi dans
une baisse ça signifie pas que tous les
tasards sont positifs ou inversement euh
or matériellement depuis le mois d'avril
je ne vois pas comment l'ifreemè aurait
pu réaliser suffisamment de prélèvements
complémentaires pour obtenir des
certitudes j'en conclu que cette
décision relève donc seulement de la
législation européenne sur les LMR
limite maximale résiduelle euh que le
que l'Europe a fixé à 20
microg par kilo alors que l'fsa qui est
quand même très prudente fixait cette
limite à 50 micog et que les États-Unis
qui sont je rappelle à l'origine et de
l'interdiction mais aussi de la
fabrication du chlordécon la fixé à 300
le principe de précaution appliqué aussi
aveuglément sur le fondement de quelques
échantillons et pour moi de nature à AV
à encore davantage angoisser les
populations sans compter qu'interdire
aux antigènes manger du poisson local
c'est accroître le diabète les maladies
cardiovasculaires qui se développent
avec le changement du bol alimentaire
mais c'est aussi concourir à la création
de circuits de commercialisation
clandestin et accroître les les achats à
l'extérieur de poisson ce qui va à
l'encontre de tout ce que nous avons
entendu cet après-midi pour l'économie
locale et pour les éléments euh
alimentaires madame la ministre je vous
demande donc si vous comptez intervenir
sur ce dossier qui fragilise à la fois
les pêcheurs et la population antiaise
et demander que davantage de poissons
soi effectivement prélevés pour savoir
si cette mesure peut-être lever ou non
alors monsieur le rapporteur euh
monsieur le président pardon Serge lcher
vous avez la parole oui merci c'est
justement un prolongement de
l'interpellation de ma collègue sur le
justement le le
le pleicon c'est que une bonne partie
finalement de la zone côtière est
entièrement interdite à la pêche et
quand on sait que l'essentiel de marin
pêcheur pêche dans cette zoneel vous
comprenez que leur activité compromise
et le revenu aussi par conséquent on
comprend qu'il c'est bien c'est bien des
mesures de de précaution de de respecter
le principe de précaution mais encore il
serait encore mieux que l'on garantisse
à ceux qui ont comme seul revenu le
produit de la pêche quand on sait que
nous sommes dans un dans une dans un
département où nous sommes les deuxèm
consommateurs de de de pêche de poisson
après le après le Japon pensez bien que
ce soit des revenus qui disparaissent
ces familles qui se trouvent en
difficulté alors madame la ministre
quelle quelle disposition pensez-vous
mettre prendre pour permettre à ce à nos
marin pêcheurs martiniicain d'avoir des
revenus CBL enin de compenser les pertes
importantes qu'ils on qu' sont en train
de subir aujourd'hui madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur madame la
sénatrice la question du chlord d'con
soulève à la fois un problème de santé
publique souvenez-vous dans quelles
conditions le plan corord d'écorne a été
mis en place et qui mobilise des moyens
considérables de l'État j'ai l'occasion
de le dire tout à l'heure puisque c'est
le premier ministre lui-même qui est
venu à la Martinique annoncer ce plan ce
plan invite le gouvernement a réalisé et
l'État a faire plus de prélèvements pour
assurer cette sécurité à l'égard de nos
compatriotes parce qu'en même temps où
je comprends le souci de préserver
l'activité pêche il faut savoir qu'à un
moment donné on a considéré que
peut-être les martiniqu les
Guadeloupéens étaient victimes d'un
empoisonnement alors vous comprendrez
bien regarde des prélèvements qui ont
été faits récemment il était je dirais
normal que dans le contexte actuel on
est pu prendre un arrêté de suspension
qui n'est pas un arrêté d'interdiction
en plus cet arrêté ne concerne pas toute
la pêche mais quelques espèces et nous
sommes en attente des conclusions de
l'AFSA qui normalement devrait
intervenir au mois de novembre et si
l'AFSA ne confirme pas benah cet arrêtée
sera levée mais bien évidemment si cet
arrêté confirme si la décision l'APSA
confirme les prélèvements tels qu'ils
ont été faits pendant cet été il faudra
bien prendre des décisions nous sommes
dans une question de santé public et
là-dessus le gouvernement ne voulait
prendre aucun risque c'est le principe
de précaution qui a été appliqué et qui
d'ailleurs a été vu en lien avec le
ministère de l'agriculture et le
ministère de la Santé qui sont largement
compétents sur cette
question alors dans le cadre du plan
clair d'corn il y a de possibilité
d'indamnisation et je peux vous dire que
cette question de l'arrêté de suspension
a été vu en lien avec les comités
régionaux de pêche puisque le préfet à
la fois celui de la Martinique et de la
guaneloupe a réuni ses comités régionaux
pour faire le point avec eux et examiner
leur situation sur le plan économique
alors nous poursuivons avec an Marie
paillette merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre ma collègue procaia
et moi-même nous avons posé des question
sur le plan santé outreemè et nous
n'avons pas obtenu de réponsse bien
précises est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner euh le montant vous pouvez nous
nous informer sur le montant des crédits
qui seront consacrés à ce plan santé
autremire alors qui
répond le le le Plan Santé autrem a été
repris dans le cas des États généraux
aujourd'hui je peux pas décliner à la
place du ministre de la Santé toute la
programmation des mesures qui sont
prévues dans le plan santé le plan santé
oututreemère il est public je peux
reprendre dans le détail les différentes
dispositions en matière de formation en
matière de numérosclusus en matière je
dirais de recherche et développement en
matière de renforcement de nos
établissements hospitaliers en matière
de risque naturel je viens de le dire en
matière effectivement de plan
particulier pour certaines maladies
maintenant la déclinaison de ce plan
découle des prérogatives du ministère de
la Santé et bien évidemment si vous
souhaitez des éléments complémentaires
on se rapprochera du ministère pour vous
les donner voilà merci monur rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
ou un petit mot Madame le Ministre tout
à l'heure bon c'était le ministre de la
Santé puis le ministre de l'Agriculture
puis le ministre de la Culture ceci ne
m'incite simplement à dire qu'il
faudrait peut-être que vous ayez une
mission interministérielle ce qui
éviterait peut-être de faire appel aux
autres collègues ça vous permettrait
d'avoir une vision plus globale vous
voyez que finalement nos propositions
tiennent debout
hein on va retenir la proposition de
Monsieur le Rapporteur bon c'est Antoine
lefè qui a la parole
ouais ouis
j'ai merci monsieur le Président je
souhaite comme notre nouveau collègue de
Lyonne revenir sur la situation de
l'agriculture les départements d'outremè
ont des cultures traditionnelles à
vocation d'exportation sur le territoire
de la métropole comme bien sûr la banane
ou la canne à sucre afin de créer les
conditions d'un développement économique
solide des départements d'autr m la
mission commune d'information a estimé
nécessaire dans son rapport de renforcer
les secteurs économiques traditionnels
des départements d'outremèes qui jouent
encore aujourd'hui un rôle central en
effet selon des données communiquées par
le ministère de l'Agriculture et de la
Pêche les cultures traditionnelles
d'exportation représentent encore
aujourd'hui plus du tiers de la valeur
de la production agricole de ces régions
34 % pour la Réunion 36 pour la la
Guadeloupe et 51 % en Martinique
l'agriculture des départements d'utremè
est aujourd'hui confronté à un défi
permettre aux exploitations d'atteindre
une taille critique madame ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement pour le
développement des filières agricoles
ultramarines je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur d'abord je
voudrais
remercier les rapporteurs et puis tous
les sénateurs qui ont participé à cette
mission parce que s'agissant des
propositions en matière agricole et
notamment sur la diversification
agricole ça rejoint tout à fait les
préoccupations du gouvernement et les
préoccupations de mon ministère bien
évidemment nous avons je dirais la
volonté de procéder à une plus grande
diversification agricole et qu'à ce
titre nous allons soutenir nous savons
qu'il y a des filières qui peuvent être
développées notamment la filière pêche
qui doit être soutenue plus fortement ou
la filière de l'élevage j'ai eu
l'occasion d'ailleurs de visiter un
centre d'élevage à la Martinique
récemment mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que nous ferons en sorte le
programme posi puisse venir en appui sur
ces secteurs nouveaux d'activités dans
le dans le domaine agricole mais que
cela se fera aussi en préservant les
cultures traditionnelles qui sont la
banane et la canne à suc qui font partie
je dirais du patrimoine de ces
territoirees et il n'est pas question à
un moment donné de considérer que une
activité se ferait au détriment d'une
autre bien au contraire c'est la
complémentarité que nous souhaitons
faire jouer ce d'autant que
l'expérimentation et et l'organisation
de la filière banane peut-être un
formidable exemple pour les autres
filières notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
les
regrouper merci alors Jean-Étienne
Antoinette monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre peut-être pour prolonger la
la proposition du du sénateur d'IG en
attendant cette mission
interministérielle on aurait souhaité
voir peut-être la présence d'autres
collègues euh de vos collègues ministres
voir même le Premier ministre pour des
questions aussi importantes que l'ARE
maire qui a euh euh mobilisé me
semble-t-il le président de la
République durant le mois de février
alors j'ai conclu tout à l'heure mon
exposé en vous demandant de façon
précise quels seront les propositions
qui seront retenus parmi les 100
propositions et dans quel calendrier
alors à défaut d'une réponse très
précise permettez-moi de prendre au
hasard trois propositions la première ça
concerne la proposition numéro 17 quelle
est votre doctrine par rapport à la
fiscalité du spatial est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de répondre de façon
favorable à la proposition qui a été
faite à savoir un rapport quant au
retombé de l'activité spatiale aux
exonérations faites à l'entreprise
grande entreprise multinational Lesa et
et j'en passe et j'en passe la deuxème
la deuxème question est relative suite à
un constat ça c'est la proposition
numéro 20 quant à l'allègement des
dettes sociales par rapport aux
collectivités locales si ces dernières
s'engagent deorénavant à honorer leur
dettes enfin concernant la Guyane il en
particulier deux communes qui rencontent
des difficultés financières
particulières qui ne peuvent pas
s'intégrer dans le plan de
restructuration financière est-ce
qu'elles peuvent prétendre à au plan
cocarde donc d'où cette proposition
d'amplifier d'étendre le plan card à
l'ensemble des autres communes d'autre
ma merci madame la ministre madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur écoutez si
vous cherchez quelque part ce que je
dévoile ce soir l'ensemble des
propositions qui vont être soumises au
comité interministériel vous comprendrez
que je ne peux pas aujourd'hui apporter
des réponses sur ce point bien
évidemment j'ai donné quelques pistes
puisque j'ai indiqué notamment sur la
question des difficultés financières
aujourd'hui rencontrées par les
collectivités ce que nous pouvons faire
et vous avez repris l'idée du plan
cocarde et j'ai parlé de restructuration
financière et j'ai indiqué qu'on fera en
sorte que ce soit encore beaucoup plus
effectif et beaucoup plus fort de
manière à soutenir les collectivités
pendant cette période difficile donc
nous n'avons pas exclu toutes les
propositions qui figurent dans le
rapport je considère qu'aujourd'hui bon
nombre de ces propositions reviennent
dans celles qui ont été formulé par les
étatsgénéraux ce qui veut dire qu'il y a
de fortes chances qu'on en retrouve au
niveau du comité interministériel ce qui
voudrait dire dire qu'il n'y aurait eu
aucune écoute ça c'est la première chose
et puis sur la question que vous
soulevez concernant le spatial je veux
simplement vous rappeler que cette
demande que je connais de la Guyane
depuis plusieurs années faut quand même
l'examiner d'un manière beaucoup plus
globale les dirigeants aujourd'hui ont
fait part de leur engagement d'aller
au-delà de leur contribution actuelle
mais il faut savoir que le spatial
dispose d'un statut particulier qui est
un statut européen et que ça nécessite
qu'on regarde les choses de plus
près merci Jean-Paul
virapoulet merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ma première question concerne le
logement social qui est un secteur
d'activité clé de l'outrem ici même
grâce au soutien de cette assemblée nous
avons fait voter dans la lodéomme un
amendement qui permet la défiscalisation
du logement social
il nous a pas été communiqué de projet
de décret mais nous avons un bon réseau
de renseignement euh et nous avons
constaté madame la ministre avec
déception d'ailleurs que le plafond de
ressources pris en compte pour le
logement la défiscalisation du logement
social outre M est inférieure au borlot
populaire alors si tel est le cas les
placements iront plus facilement vers le
en métropole vers le borleau populaire
que vers le logement social outreem je
pense qu'il faut revoir cette question
parce que aujourd'hui le bâtiment a
licencié plus de 5000 personnes à la
Réunion les grands travaux ne
reprendront pas tout de suite et c'est
véritablement le grand secteur
d'activité c'est le premier secteur dans
un ou 2 ans ce sont les titic qui
passeront devant deviendront le premier
secteur mais aujourd'hui c'est le
logement social alors je compte sur vous
pour revoir cette question l'étudier
sérieusement en relation avec les
promoteurs et avec l'industrie du
bâtiment et les travaux publics parce
que un une mauvaise fixation du plafond
risque de coûter à l'état beaucoup plus
cher qu'une incitation raisonnable et
raisonnée le deuxème secteur c'est
l'ttic là aussi on a pris connaissance
du projet de décret et on l'a soumis à
nos amis de
différentes association qui s'occupe du
développement des titic outremè qui
tasse de devenir le premier secteur de
développement
et nous avons constaté il manque dans ce
décret un certain nombre d'activités qui
sont clés pour l'avenir éditeur de
logiciel service de distribution édition
de jeu électronique téléservice
téléactivité multimédia production
audiovisuel et cetera je me suis permis
de transmettre de vous transmettre
directement madame la ministre
l'ensemble des secteurs qui ne sont pas
concernés et si tel était le cas le
décret tel qu'il est prévu ne
concernerait que 36 % du secteur
d'activité étic reconnaissez avec moi
que pour un secteur clé de notre
développement ça serait dommage de
l'étrangler au lieu de lui donner
l'oxygène nécessaire pour un
développement de l'emploi l'emploi
empêche bien des misères outreem et on
en a bien besoin puis de deux petites
questions rapides on l'a vu avec la
pêche en Martinique mais c'est vrai
aussi dans d'autres région d'outremer
notamment la Réunion euh aujourd'hui les
traités européens nous permettent
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans
l'adaptation avec cette cellule qui sera
créée auprès de vous-même auprès du
Premier ministre la commission la
mission propose auprès du Premier
ministre et nous sommes solidaires de sa
proposition envisagez-vous une directive
au cas par cas par secteur nécessaire
nécessitant une adaptation ou bien une
directive communautaire un
peu clé qui balaye plusieurs secteurs et
donne à l'outremère les moyens de son
développement s'agissant du rsage
thermique il y a eu un grand débat
ici vous verrez dans le Journal officiel
que nous avons dit clairement parce que
c'était avant l'accord Bino mais
l'accord Bino c'est 3 ans mais l'accord
Bino c'est un accord tampon parce que le
RSA n'était pas appliqué are maire mais
si on nous posait la question
aujourd'hui vous vous référez au Joo et
vous verrez que Monsieur le Commissaire
euh chargé de de mettre en œuvre le RSA
Martin HCH avait bien clairement accepté
que la période de non application du RSA
outreem serait transitoire puisque je
crois qu'à l'article 34 c'est en 2011
que le RSA doit s'appliquer autre maire
en tout cas je m'accroche à ce débat aux
engagements qui ont été pris par le haut
commomissaire chargé de l'intégration
ici il faut que le RSA et donc le RSA
jeune soit appliqué à l'outreem à force
de faire deux poids de mesure c'est ça
qui crée le clash outre ma ah votre
temps a été explosé Jean-Paul
virapoulet
allez madame la ministre
oui monsieur sénateur il y a beaucoup de
questions dans votre intervention
d'abord vous faites état au projet de
décret du seller outremer je voudrais
simplement vous rappeler au moment où
l'amendement a été adopté le plafond qui
a été retenu pour le plafond de loyer et
se situé entre 8 et 10 € la proposition
aujourd'hui qui figure dans le décret
est un plafond autour de 9 € le mètre
carré qui correspond certes à la voit un
plafond qui est celui entre le pls et le
lls donc on considère qu'aujourd'hui ce
plafond répond à la gamme des logements
intermédiaires des logements sociaux
alors pour les nticc le décret n'est pas
complètement finalisé nous examinerons
la liste au cas par cas des suggestions
qui ont été faites simplement j'attire
votre attention sur le fait qu'il faut
pas dénaturer le texte l'objectif
c'était quand même de faire une zone de
de faire à partir des N titic une zone
franche globale d'activité donc un
secteur prioritaire et qu'à ce titre là
il faut veiller à ce qu'on soit bien
dans le champ des nticc alors vous vous
soulevez par ailleurs la question de
l'application de l'article
280 299 2 du traité pour permettre des
adaptations en se posant la question de
savoir est-ce qu'il faudrait pas une
directive communautaire moi je crois
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
forcément il faille aller vers une
directive peut-être qu'il faudra le
travailler avec la commission ce que je
note aujourd'hui c'est que la Commission
considère à juste titre que nous avons
peut-être pas utilisé pour les régions
ultrapériphérique et nos régions
d'outremè en général plus cette
disposition de l'article 2992 qui nous
aurait permis les adaptation dont nous
avons besoin en terme de cohérence je
dirais des politiques communautaires
alors pour le RSA je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprise s'il y a eu un débat
où effectivement à un moment donné les
parlementaires ont fait savoir qu'ils
souhaitaient l'application du ça en même
temps qu'elle s'appliquait au niveau de
la France métropolitaine par ailleurs
lorsque la question était soulevé pour
sortir de la crise il faut savoir que le
gouvernement avait proposé cette
application du
RSA le gouvernement avait proposé cette
application du RSA mais la solution n'a
pas été retenue parce qu'il fallait être
dans une démarche qui considérit que
peut-être ça devrait être un revenu
complémentaire ce que le gouvernement a
considéré que ça ne pouvait pas être un
revenu complémentaire et c'est le
dispositif RSCA qui a été préféré à
celui du RSA bien évidemment l'accord a
été signé en ces termes on est lié à cet
accord maintenant je viens de répondre
au sédateur Gilot que s'il y avait les
moyens pour avancer de manière à
permettre une anticipation du RSA en
sortant du RSCA le gouvernement n'est
pas opposé à accompagner toute démarche
en ce sens mais pour l'instant nous
sommes dans une application du RSCA et
il ne peut y avoir un cumul des deux
dispositifs puisque le rsea est un RSA
adapté en réalité merci la parole est au
président André
Dulay merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre les lors de son passage la
mission a constaté combien les retombées
financières du Centre spatial de courou
était faible pour les collectivités
territoriales comment
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle
va-t-elle s'appliquer est-ce que ce
centre spatial sera inclus dans les
grandes entreprises de réseau qui
permettront de équilibrer sur l'ensemble
du territoire tout en respectant les
accords internationaux les retombées de
ce
centre madame la
ministre le le Centre Spatial un statut
particulier je dit un statut européen ne
P pas la taxe professionnelle
aujourd'hui le centre spatial participe
à l'aménagement du territoire puisqu'il
contribue à la réalisation d'un certain
nombre d'équipements et sa participation
est de l'ordre de 23 millions
aujourd'hui sur 3 ans 5 ans sur 5 ans
aujourd'hui la question ne peut pas être
abordée en ces termees c'est vrai que se
pose la question de la des retombées
financières du spatial mais il faut
savoir aussi que nous sommes dans un
secteur très concurrentiel et avec je
dirais l'arrivée de d'autres pays qui
sur le champ du spatial peuvent-être
concurrencés aujourd'hui la France et
l'Europe sur cette question il faut être
prudent sur les modalités de
participation du
spatial merci la parole est à Michel
magrass merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre le 8 octobre dernier
le conseil territorial de
saint-bartelemie a adopté une
délibération visant à demandé au
gouvernement une d'engager le processus
d'accession à son statut de PTOM
il s'agit pour nous d'abord d'une
démarche de cohérence puisque nous avons
un statut de spécialité législative et
que l'Europe en droit nationale et que
l'Europe impose à la France et à donc à
toutes les régions ultrapériphériques un
régime de d'identité législative
autrement dit si nous restons RUP la
France continuera l'Europe continuera
via la France à nous imposer euh un
régime de donc des obligations dans les
domaines de compétences qu'elle nous a
déjà transféré de même euh certaines
contraintes sont difficilement
acceptables je voudrais juste vous citer
un exemple la directive européenne sur
l'essence a eu pour effet une
augmentation immédiate de 22 centimes du
litre qui a eu pour conséquence sur une
année un coût supplémentaire d'un
montant plus de deux fois supérieur à ce
que l'Europe a prévu de nous accorder au
titre du POI parce que nous étions
encore commune de la Guadeloupe donc on
nous donne 1 € et on en paye deux le
enfin le PIB par par habitant de
saint-barthelémi étant supérieur à la
moyenne européenne il il est évident que
nous allons définitivement fermer la
porte de l'accès aux fonds européens
alors il s'agit pas pour autant pour la
collectivité de saint-bartelemi de ne
pas appliquer les normes européennes
nous souhaitons simplement les adapter
et disons les les mettre aux dimensions
de notre collectivité parce qu'il s'agit
pour nous d' d'une qualité à offrir à
nos concitoyens à nos visiteurs et à la
planète à cet égard madame la ministre
je souhaitis donc connaître euh comment
s'opérera cette jonction entre
l'identité législative européenne et la
spécialité législative locale et
pourriez-vous m'indiquer quelles sont
les étapes du processus et les
conditions à remplir pour qu'il puisse
aboutir c'est une deuxième question qui
porte le le la Présidente nous a dit en
début de séance que j'avais déposé une
PPL sur visant à permettre à
saint-bartelémi de d'imposer chez les
non résident les revenus de sources
locales j'aimerais savoir si vous êtes
en mesure dès à présent de me donner euh
le sentiment du gouvernement sur cette
problématique enfin une juste je
m'adresse au rapporteur le collègue
denischeveri qui est absent a souhaité
attirer l'attention du rapporteur sur le
fait que dans les comes il y a également
donc des problématiques communes avec
les départements d'outremè et propres
collectivités d'outremè à certaines
collectivités d'outremè je le précise et
il souhait savoir si la mission il
constate que le président avait voulu
étendre les États généraux à l'ensemble
de l'outremè et il vous demande si la
miss à l'intention d'être étendu à
certaines collectivités je vous remercie
le ministre et monsieur le rapporteur
bien entendu alors votre question ESTs
technique monsieur le sénateur nécessite
qu'on le regarde de plus près ce que je
peux vous dire déjà c'est qu'en
s'agissant du statut RUP ou PTOM il faut
qu'il y a un vrai choix de la
collectivité on peut pas être à moitié
RUP et à moitié PTOM donc il faudra à un
moment donné faire un choix un choix au
regard des avantages qu' le statut de
RUP par rapport à celui de PTO om qui
permet effectivement de déroger aux
règles communautaires dans certains cas
aujourd'hui il semblerait que
Saint-Martin veille faire le choix
d'aller vers le statut de PTOM bien
évidemment si cette demande était
saint-bartelémi pardon saint-bartelémi
faisait le choix d'aller vers un statut
de PTOM le gouvernement accompagnera
cette demande auprès de la commission
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler hier au
commissaire du développement à ce sujet
simplement au niveau de la procédure
puisque vous avez soulevé la question de
l'application du droit qui aurait déjà
été transposé dans le droit du droit
communautaire qui a été transposé dans
le droit national il continuera de
s'appliquer euh à vérifier mais sur le
principe il continuera de s'appliquer et
pour le reste ça permettra à
saint-bartin notamment sur certaines à
saint-bartelémi sur certaines règles
communautaires de déroger notamment au
niveau des droits de droine puisque
c'est l'une des préoccupations pour
avoir des recettes complémentaires alors
pour votre projet de loi euh bien
évidemment nous y sommes favorables je
vous avveis répondu lors de
l'examen de la loi concernant la
Nouvelle Calédonie simplement il faut
aujourd'hui contte tenu des priorités
entre Saint-Martin qui a fait la même
demande nous regardons par rapport au
calendrier parlementaire s'il y a un
créneau pour qu'on puisse débattre de de
de ce projet de loi mais il n'y a aucune
difficulté sur le
principe monsieur le rapporteur
oui je remercie mon collègue de nous
avoir posé cette question qui est
peut-être la meilleure question de la
journée hein puisqu'il nous demande si
on va continuer euh le rapport qu'on a
fait euh en dépassant les qure d'Es et
en allant dans les autres territoire
alors ça ne relève pas de nous puisque
la mission bah elle est terminée hein le
rapport a été rendu et donc la mission
n'existe plus à partir de là il y a un
groupe qui probablement va se mettre en
place de travail et si le président du
Sénat et le le bureau et les présidents
de groupe considèrent que notre travail
a été de de qualité positif
peut-être on sait jamais qu'on
continuera à travailler ce qui permettra
d'alimenter de façon positives les
réflexions du du gouvernement il est
bien évident qu'on a un acquis et que
cet acquis ça serait dommage de ne pas
le valoriser la valorisation des acquis
c'est important monsieur le Président et
donc j'espère
que le Sénat tiendra compte de de cet
acquis de
qualité bien je crois que vous avez
réponse alors nous poursuivons car il y
a de nombreux inscrits encore Christian
Quinta
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la crise sans
précédent qui a affecté en février
dernier durant plusieurs semaines la
Guadeloupe la Martinique et la Réunion a
posé la question du modèle de
développement et de société souhaitaable
pour les départements d'outrem et plus
largement pour l'ensemble de l'outrem
français comme l'a souligné le président
de la République le 19 février dernier
un cycle historique s'est achevé en
outrem qui au-delà des réponses
conjoncturelles appellent des réponses à
long terme les états généraux de
l'Outremer ont été l'occasion d'une
forte participation des ultramarins
cette formidable volonté de mouvement
doit maintenant se traduire par des
décisions concrètes à court terme ou
plus structurel afin d'engager un vaste
plan de modernisation de l'outreem et de
rénover en profondeur le mode de sa
relation avec la métropole alors madame
la ministre voici ma question
pouvez-vous nous faire le point des
synthèses des travaux de ces états
généraux où le thème de la gouvernance a
été l'un des sujets les plus évoqués et
nous préciser les leçons vous en avez
tiré comme les actions que vous
envisagez je vous
remercie madame la
ministre ce que je note au travers des
réflexions qui ont été menées sur le
terme de la gouver
c'est qu'il y a vraiment une volonté de
pas avoir un modèle unique je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure les ultramarins attendent
à ce qu'on prenne en compte leurs
attentes territoire par territoire parce
que l'histoire de ces territoires n'est
pas identique et qu'ils souhaitent
établir des relations différenciées en
fonction du lieu gérographique dans
lequel ils vivent les Guyanais ne
souhaitent pas la même chose que les
Martiniquais que les Guadeloupéens que
les réunionnis que la Polynésie et j'ai
même indiqué un jour lors du débat qu'on
s'achaminera peut-être par une gestion
où on aura 11 territoires avec 11
statuts particuliers on est vraiment
dans une réponse de faire du surmesure
pour être sûr qu'on est dans une réponse
aux attentes de ces populations alors ce
que je note aussi c'est que cette
volonté se traduit par plus d'État un
état qui soit plus présent un état qui
garantisse l'intérêt général et un état
qui soit je dirais garant des libertés
d'une plus grande justice sociale ce
message il est très fort donc il va
s'accompagner vraisemblablement par une
déconcentration des services de l'État
un renforcement je dirais des moyens de
de l'État dans les territoires et
peut-être une meilleure cohérence de
l'intervention des services de l'État
dans les territoires d'outrem donc je
pense que c'est très important que cette
question soit abordée aujourd'hui mais
je voudrais pas que le cœur des États
généraux se limite à la question de la
gouvernance parce qu'au travers de la
question de la gouvernance on voit bien
qu'en matière de politique économique de
politique de l'emploi de politique de la
formation il y a beaucoup à faire il y a
des fortes attendes et il faut pouvoir
répondre aux préoccupations de nos
compatriotes d're ma la parole est au
président Serge Larcher
oui madame la secrétaire la ministre je
vous interroger sur la situation du
tourisme à Martinique la France est la
première destination touristique mondial
cette affirmation interpelle aux Antill
françaises quand on connaît sur place la
qualité de l'industrie touristique
aggravée par la crise sociale de février
2009 actuellement les hôtels fermes les
licenciement économiques se multiplie
ainsi 500 emplois ont été perdus en
l'espace de 18 mois ce constat est
Toutant plus cruel quand on sait que
l'ensemble des îles non francophone de
la Caraïbe ont fait le choix du tourisme
comme premier secteur de développement
économique certes des mesures locales et
immédiates des collectivités régionales
sont indispensables mais une forte
implication de l'État est nécessaire
pour la mise en œuvre d'un plan de un
plan vigoureux de soutien financier et
de relance du secteur visitant la le
salon Top r en septembre dernier vous
avez affirmé vouloir vous impliquer
fortement à côté des collectivités
appendant même à une électro un
électrochoc pour qu'enfin le tourisme
puisse se développer are m aussi madame
la ministre je vous demande nombre de
questions quelle part l'état entend-il
prendre dans la relance du tourisme aux
Antilles françaises 1 quels sont les
vraies mesures d'accompagnement et les
outils financiers mis en place pour
sauver ce secteur
2 quelles instructions sont données au
chef de service de l'État localement à
la Martinique pour éviter la cascade de
dépôt de bilan to enfin 4 pourquoi les
services fiscaux et avec eux berc
estcecutil les destinations tiers des
lieux accueillant les séminaires de
formation alors que ce potentiel de
clientèle est indispensable notamment en
période d de basse saison ensuite
quelles sont les mesures prises
conjointement par votre ministère et
celui du transport pour désenclaver la
Martinique et la Guadeloupe et ouvrir le
ciel des Antilles à partir de voici
Charles de Gaul enfin Madame la Ministre
les Antill veulent faire de ce secteur
le prveecteur de développement le
gouvernement est-il prêt à les
accompagner de manière durable je vous
remercie madame la ministre vous avez la
parole effectivement monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison de rappeler la
déclaration que j'ai faite à topra
concernant le tourisme ce d'autant que
le tourisme est un secteur prioritaire
pour l'outremère parce que nous savons
que c'est un secteur à fort potentialité
notamment en terme d'emploi alors sur le
tourisme je crois qu'il faut agir à
trois niveaux il faut agir à court terme
à moyen terme et à plus long terme à
court terme compte tenu de la crise
sociale que nous venons de traverser il
faut relancer l'activité et ça passera
forcément par des actions de
communication une sensibilisation sur la
destination c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai fait savoir au Comité du
Tourisme de la Martinique que j'étais
disposé à accompagner cette démarche dès
lors que cette démarche s'inscrve dans
des actions dont on pouvait mesurer les
on pouvait mesurer les conséquences
réelles sur le nombre de touristes qui
pourrai être accueillis à partir de la
prochaine saison donc nous travaillons
sur cet aspect des choses et j'aurai
l'occasion de me rendre très
prochainement à la Martinique avec Hervé
Novelli pour présenter quelques
disosition à ce sujet alors à moyen
terme euh à court terme aussi il y a
tous les dispositifs d'aide de soutien
pour que les entreprises fassent face à
la situation particulièrement difficile
notamment je vais pas citer le plan
corail d'appurement des dettes
d'étalement des dettes et cetera ça fait
partie effectivement des mesures de
soutien des entreprises pour éviter que
les entre que les hôtels ne ferment
comme on a pu le constater ces derniers
mois alors à moyen terme nous avons tout
le dispositif de la lodéum puisque vous
savez qu'en tant que secteur prioritaire
il dispose de moyens considérabl
aujourd'hui aussi bien au niveau de la
défiscalisation que les exonérations de
charges je pense à la rénovation
hôtelière je vais pas lister tous ces
dispositifs ce que je voudrais dire en
revanche c'est que nous ne pourrons pas
relancer la le tourisme si nous n'en
réglons pas deux problèmes d'abord celui
de la confiance et pour établir la
confiance il faut faire en sorte que la
tension sociale qui existe sur nos
territoires ça pèse parce que c'est la
seule façon de revaloriser la
destination nous avons des fortes
potentialités dans le domaine du
tourisme il faut qu'on puisse baisser
d'urgence la question des tensions
sociales qui s'opèrent en outreemè ça
c'est la première chose et puis l'autre
chose il faut aussi que les martiniquis
les Guadeloupéens alors c'était
peut-être parce que je suis ultramarine
je me suis autorisé à lui dire s'apoprie
je dirais ce secteur d'activité et ne
considère pas que le tourisme est
forcément le secteur dans lequel on
espère avoir un emploi parce qu'on n pas
trouvé d'autres emplois il faut
permettre à des cadres d'occuper des
responsabilités pour mon aussi que dans
le tourisme ça peut être un ascenseur
social et que ce n'est pas simplement un
secteur où on y va parce que on n pas eu
d'autres choix et cette question
d'appropriation vous le savez très bien
parce que nous avons une histoire
douloureuse il faut qu'on puisse
dépasser cette difficulté et si on
arrive à passer cette difficulté je
crois que tout le monde pourra
contribuer à faire du tourisme l'une des
premières activités en
outreem merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur
oui si vous permettez monsieur le
Président simplement jeis dire à la
suite de Madame le Ministre puisqu'elle
s'est autorisé à le dire que si elle
navait pas dit je l'aurais dit même
n'étant pas ultra marin donc c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai ressenti je crois
qu'il y a il y a un vrai problème il y a
tout ce qu'il faut pour réussir et c'est
un problème après d'homme et de femme et
c'est donc là qu'il y a le problème à
résoudre merci Daniel Laurent vous avez
la parole
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mes chers collègues madame la
ministre je souhaiterais vous poser deux
questions sur les prix et la concurrence
dans les pays d'outremè en matière de
grande distribution l'Autorité de la
Concurrence a souligné dans son avis
rendu en septembre l'importance des
écarts de prix entre la métropole et les
départements d'outremè appelant à plus
de concurrence dans ce
secteur plus de 50 % des écarts de prix
relevés sont ASI supérieur à 55 %. ce
constat rejoint les données issues du
relevé de prix effectué par la mission
commune
d'information madame la ministre quelle
mesures comptez-vous prendre dans ce
domaine que pensez-vous des propositions
de l'Autorité de la concurrence et
notamment de celle tendant à créer des
centrales d'approvisionnement et de
stockage régional qui permettraient de
réduire les coûts et de et de mieux
faire jouer la concurrence entre
fabricant et intermédiaire merci Madame
la
Ministre la question des prix est
centrale aujourd'hui effectivement
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a rendu un
rapport qui montre des écarts de prix
importants je crois que l'Autorité de la
concurrence ira au-delà de ce rapport
puisque elle m'a annoncé j'ai été amené
à recevoir le président de cette
autorité de poursuivre en faisant des
enquêtes complémentaires s'il y a n é de
renforcer la législation nous le ferons
donc ça c'est la première chose pour le
reste en ce qui concerne les proposition
de l'Autorité de la concurrence
notamment avec cette plateforme de
centralisation je crois que ça
nécessiteêt expertisé parce qu'il
faudrait pas à partir d'une recherche
des meilleurs coûts nous créons aussi
d'autres monopoles qui au bout du compte
feraient augmenter le prix des
marchandise donc tout ça nécessite une
expertise on a pris en compte ces
propositions on les examinera pour qu'à
un moment donné elle puisse être mise en
application
voilà merci bien alors nous poursuivons
c'est Lucienne malovri qui a la parole
elle l'attendait depuis
longtemps question très courte monsieur
le Président Madame le
Ministre la mission d'information a pu
constater au cours de son déplacement
les difficultés rencontrées dans
l'identification des bases imposables de
la fiscalité loc dans les domes les
services fiscaux mènent déjà des actions
bien sûr dans le sens d'une meilleure
identification mais ces efforts semble
encore très
insuffisant quel renforcement des
actions le gouvernement envisage-t-il
Madame le Ministre pour répondre aux
besoins impérieux d'améliorer cette
identification merci merci madame la
ministre vous posez la question
effectivement des bases imposables il
faut qu'on puisse les élargir au
aujourd'hui en notre mer c'est ça qui va
permettre de fiabiliser et de pérenniser
les recettes des collectivités locales
ce travail a été à un moment donné
proposé à l'ensemble des collectivités
d'outremè en 2003 je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on puisse le
relancer l'État est prêt à accompagner
les collectivités en renforçant les
moyens qu'il disposent pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse arriver à cette base
beaucoup plus élargie qui permettra
d'augmenter les recettes des
expérimentations ont été menées
notamment en Guiane et ça permis
d'augmenter considérablement la recette
de certaines communes et on peut s'en
féliciter je crois qu'il faut qu'on
poursuive dans ce sens merci c'est à
Marc
lameni vous avez la parole monsieur le
séndateur merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ma question donc concerne
l'accroissement du produit de la
fiscalité locale la mission
d'information a constaté que les taux de
recouvrement de l'impôt sur le revenu
dans les départements d'outremer étai
très inférieur au taux en métropole 80 %
contre plus de 98 %. Bery n'a pas pu
fournir les données relatives à la
fiscalité locale toutefois il est il est
probable que le recouvrement des impôts
locaux soit également déficients des
donc ma question donc à Madame la
Ministre concerne donc est-ce qu'il
est-ce que des efforts supplémentaires
sont-ils envisagés pour accroître
l'efficacité du recouvrement des impôts
locaux dans les département d'outrem je
vous remercie voilà on est dans la
fiscalité locale madame la ministre je
voudrais répondre à monsieur le sénateur
en disant que la réponse est en lien
avec celle que je viens d'apporter à
votre collègue bien évidemment il faut
d'abord renforcer les moyens pour
permettre que ce taux de recouvrement se
rapproche de celui de la métropole et
puis dans un deuxè temps il faudra aussi
élargir les bases fiscales pour
permettre de garantir aux collectivités
des recettes beaucoup plus importantes
mais ce travail pourra se faire aussi en
lien avec les collectivités
locales François denron vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues malgré la
spécificité des domes l'organisation de
l'administration déconcentrée de l'État
n'est guerre différente de de celle de
la métropole or le schéma actuellement
retenu n'est pas satisfaisant d'une part
il convient de mieux adapter les
structures de l'administration locale
aux besoins locaux les nouvelles
structures qui se mettent en place peu à
peu en métropole dans le cadre de la
RGPP ne saurait être appliqué tel quel
sur des territoires tels que les Domme
d'autre part incontestablement dans
plusieurs domaines les moyens de de
l'administration d'État ne sont pas
suffisants pour faire face à des
situations très particulières je citerai
notamment le cas des services chargés de
la concurrence qui ne sont pas
suffisamment dimensionnés par rapport
aux enjeux dans des économies
naturellement
oligopololistique sans parler de la
déficience des services chargés du
travail et de l'emploi face à des
pratiques très développées de travail
dissimulé en en réalité conjointement à
leur désir d'une plus grande autonomie
institutionnelle les DOM demandent un
renouvellement de la présence de l'État
ce qui ne veut pas dire loin de là moins
d'État mais au contraire une meilleure
reconnaissance de leur spécificité dans
leur prise en charge par
l'administration
déconcentrée dans ces conditions madame
la ministre pourriez-vous nous faire
part des pistes envisagées par le
gouvernement pour réformer
l'administration déconcentrée outre M
madame la
ministre je crois que la question
effectivement de l'organisation des
services de l'État en outreemire il faut
pas peut-être se dire qu'on pourrait
tout modéliser donc il faut regarder la
situation territoire par territoire
aujourd'hui il est certain qu'il faut
qu'on puisse organiser les services de
l'État différemment il faut peut-être
aussi revoir les missions plutôt
concentrer les services sur certains
territoires dans des missions très
précises qui correspond à un besoin je
crois que la question certes elle se
pose en terme de moyens mais en fait la
question qui nous a surtout été posée
c'est plutôt d'avoir mieux d'État que
plus d'État donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
rechercher l'efficacité il faut chercher
une meilleure cohérence il faut chercher
une meilleure coordination ça passe
aussi par le regroupement sous une même
autorité tout ça doit être vu en
fonction des territoires et c'est bien
l'objet de notre réflexion et qui va
déboucher vraisemblablement sur un
certain nombre de propositions puisque
comme je vous l'ai dit il y a la volonté
de renforcer l'action de l'État dans les
territoires mais ça passera peut-être
par des moyens mais pas simplement par
des moyens il faut aussi entendre par
mieux d'État et mieux
organisé merci George
patient madame la ministre vous n'avez
aussi pas répondu à ma demande
de maintien de la SA d'HLM bon c'est une
simple remarque ça va pas être l'objet
de de ma question ma question portera
sur un sujet qui a été traité dans dans
le rapport et qui concerne le schéma
minier euh de
Guyane comme vous le savez jusqu'à ce
schéma l'activité horifèire est une
activité d'importance en Guyane on y
exporter plus de 4 tonnes à 5 tonnes de
chaque année or depuis euh les travaux
d'élaboration de ce schéma minier
l'activité légale a été plus ou moins
arrêtée euh beaucoup de petits
orpailleurs ne trouvent plus euh
à le renouvellement de leur aux leur
autorisation d'exploitation mais en
contre-partie les orpilleurs clandestins
continuent à piller et d'après toutes
les informations qu'on leur peut avoir
c'est quasiment 6 tonnes d'or qui sont
euh qui disparaissent du sous-sol
guyanais chaque année sans aucune
rentaubée au niveau du pays alors cuide
de ce schéma minier puisque comme vous
le
savez ça a été considéré comme un verou
au niveau du rapport du Sénat ce schéma
est très décrié en guyan mais bon on
sait pas plus il est toujours pas adopté
mais pour autant les autorisations
d'exploitation ne sont pas délivrées et
l'activité est l'activité légale est
quasiment
é merci madame la
ministre
monsieur sénateur vous savez mieux que
moi comment a été décidé la réalisation
de ce schéma minier antérieurement il
n'y avait rien et vous savez que ça a
été un sujet très difficile puisqueun
grand projet industriel qui devait
s'implanter en Guyane et qui était
porteur de nombre d'emplois considérabl
pour la guyan n'a pas pu être réalisé
faute de documents d'aménagement du
territoire c'est bien pour cela que le
schéma minier a été engagé aujourd'hui
il est sujet à des observation des
réflexions de la part des collectivités
aujourd'hui ce travail a été finalisé
sur la base effectivement de
concertation avec à la fois les
orpilleurs à la fois je dirais les
collectivités locales qui ont été
consultées à un moment donné si
aujourd'hui il y a nécessité d'une
articulation et de revoir ce schéma pour
tenir compte d'une activité économique
le schéma minier viendra en consultation
devant le conseil général et devant le
conseil régional il y aura tout loisir
effec ement de prendre en compte vos
observations à ce moment-là parce que
parallèlement il faut que ce schéma
minier soit en articulation avec le
schéma d'aménagement régional don nous
sommes en attente de ces premiers
cadrages donc vous comprenez que le
schéma minier doit s'articuler avec le
schéma d'aménagement régional la
procédure il fallait l'engager parce que
c'était préjudiciable à la Guyane de ne
pas avoir ces documents de cadrage
notamment par rapport à l'activité de
aurifère donc je crois qu'il était
important d'avancer mais non nous serons
à l'écoute des collectivités dans le
cadre de la consultation qui est
obligatoire alors pour la shlm je veux
bien vous répondre he s'agissant de la
shlm vous savez que nous avons le souci
de régler ce dossier très rapidement
pour deux raisons d'abord pour préserver
je dirais les intérêts financiers des
collectivités parce que vous savez qu'il
y a des montants de garantie qui sont
pas négligeables et donc il ne faut pas
qu'on aille vers une
liquidation judiciaire et que d'autre
part je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de
locataires il y a beaucoup de guyanais
qui qu'on règle la situation de la shlm
parce que nous ne pouvons pas faire les
opérations de réhabilitation et nous ne
pouvons pas construire des opérations
important notamment dans le cadre de
l'opération de Cayenne qui est financé
dans le cadre de l'EN rue et je crois
qu'il est urgent de trouver une solution
par rapport à la gouvernance de ce au
niveau de ce bailleur social c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est à l'écoute
on attend des propositions mais avec
benoî par nous prendre une décision très
rapidement merci Claude l vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je veux évoquer le
problème de l'aide à la balance bon il
faut pas que les les collègues M prenne
sur le terme l'aide à la balance c'est
un complément de rémunération qui est
accordé au planteur hein lorsqu'il livre
la canne à l'usine alors vous savez que
c'est une aide qui est absolument
indispensable euh
puisquelle c'est un complément de de de
de rémunération qui euh permet une
fourniture effective à l'usine et pour
la Martinique il n'y a plus qu'une usine
comme vous le savez qui
est qui est en réalité on peut dire
porté à bout de bras par la collectivité
départementale la collectivité régionale
alors pourquoi je pose la question c'est
parce que en Martinique l'aide à la
balance est une aide à laquelle
participe fortement le Conseil Général
alors que en Guadeloupe et à la Réunion
l'État prend en charge totalement cette
aide à la balance donc compte tenu
contte tenu de la situation qui a déjà
été évoquée à plusieurs reprises
évidemment président de conseil général
que je suis ne cesse de réclamer
d'ailleurs même avant les difficultés
actuelles que l'on rétablisse certaine
équité dans cette affaire je vois pas
pourquoi euh la Martinique un régime là
très particulier là on a fait de
l'adaptation curieusement et alors que à
la Réunion
et à la Guadeloupe bon ben l'état fait
face entièrement à cette aide à la
balance alors nous avons soulevé le
problème plusieurs fois auprès de
plusieurs ministres de l'Agriculture
alors il y en a un c'est Monsieur
Dominique busra à l'époque en 2005 qui
nous avait euh
pratiquement donné un avis favorable sur
une prise en charge par l'État
malheureusement il n'a pas réalisé ça
avant de quitter le
euh son ministère et donc ce que je
voudrais vous demander madame la
ministre c'est d'intervenir euh pour
d'intervenir auprès de votre collègue
ministre de l'Agriculture actuellement
pour lui demander euh s'il serait
d'accord hein pour pour que ce qu'avait
prévu monsieur busfo se réalise ce
serait même de notre part une demande
urgente que ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que c'est qu'une réforme sur ce plan-là
prennent effet avant la campagne
prochaine compte tenu des difficultés
que nous avons déjà évoqué Claude lis
madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur lise j'ai
eu connaissance effectivement de cette
difficulté je sais que l'aide à la
balance n'est pas applicable à la
Martinique et d'ailleurs je me suis
préoccupée de savoir les raisons qui
font qu'eectivement en Guadeloupe l'aide
à balance est appliqué notamment à
l'usine Gardelle et pas en Martinique
donc ce problème je vais le regarder et
je m'engage à vous apporter une réponse
mais je vous donnerai la réponse
aujourd'hui j'ai eu connaissance et je
n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de le
traiter en lien avec le ministère de
l'agriculture mais je vous apporterai
une réponse très précise là-dessus pour
expliquer pourquoi il y a ce traitement
différencié au niveau de l'aide à la
balance merci et le dernier orateur
inscrit Sophie
joissin monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre la mission sénatoriale sur la
situation dans les domes a préconisé la
mise en place d'un statut de l'étudiant
ultramarin de même que le rapport des
professeurs Hervé Bossard et Pascal Jean
qui a été remis au gouvernement en mai
dernier qu'en est-il aujourd'hui des
possibilités de continuité territoriale
prévu par la lodom et quand ces
étudiants pourront-ils bénéficier d'un
dispositif Erasmus régional spécifique
pour faciliter leur mobilité
géographique enfin le projet de création
de deux grandes universités francophones
l'une pour l'océan Indien et l'autre
pour les Antilles lag guuyan
progressil madame la ministre
aujourd'hui vous savez que nous sommes
dans une réflexion concernant la refonte
globale de la dotation continuité
territoriale et de la politique en la
matière aujourd'hui s'il y a une volonté
d'ouverture de nos universit
avec des universités dans
l'environnement régional des territoires
vous imaginez qu'il faudra qu'on prenne
en compte le fait que au titre de la
continuité territoriale nous puissions
élargir le dispositif et qu'il ne soit
pas simplement limité à une relation et
des déplacements des étudiants entre les
territoires d'outremer et la métropole
donc moi j'ai le souci aussi de prendre
en compte les besoins des étudiants dans
ce secteur rien n'est arrêté nous sommes
en train d'y réfléchir merci vous venez
de suivre un débat sur la situation des
départements d'outrem merci de votre
fidélité et à très bientôt sur Public
Sénat